the other day we were talking on the
show and luke mentioned he saw some
report about u.s diplomats
getting um swabbed into bum-bum
by china and uh it turns out it's a real
story
u.s diplomats were going to china and
china gave them
the infamous covid19
buttswab and the us is extremely angry
about it but come on what's joe biden
going to do he's going to be like hey
look here you know
china i'll do whatever you say and
that's what's going to happen
the u.s is entirely shifting its focus
away from china even after things like
this
towards russia syria sanctions on russia
are coming
joe biden just launched an airstrike on
syria and
and all of a sudden all these democrats
are like actually this time it's okay
even though many of them
were saying that donald trump had no
authority to do this now joe biden does
it
and this is proportional great well i'll
be
you know look my respect to the
progressives who are calling out joe
biden
really angry because they're like yo i
voted for you to give me a check
not to blow up kids in a foreign country
but
i'm kind of like you know we warned you
man and
all i can really say is welcome to the
fight thank you for for pushing back on
this insanity and i agree with you
joe biden's supposed to be giving
american americans cover relief he's not
doing that
so we got those stories we got this
crazy story about a giant golden trump
at cpac that's making everybody i don't
know
angry actually like even conservatives
are getting mad that the absurdity of
this golden idol of trump
and then we have some other funny
stories we'll see we get to there's one
where apparently american airlines
reported a strange cylindrical object
floating over it
so military weapon aliens we'll see
hanging out with us today we got
drew holden how's it going man you want
to introduce yourself yeah hey guys
my name is drew i'm back on the program
really excited about it
uh you may know me from twitter for
being the annoying guy with all the
lists
uh if you've if you've seen the the list
emoji i use it far too often the thread
emoji
uh and i'm i'm happy to be here talking
about a lot of stuff obviously we've had
a lot of hypocrisy afoot lately and so
uh it's all it's always good talking
about liberal hypocrisy i find there's
there's usually enough of it to go
there's just so much it's like mining
and then just it's just there
yeah you know like this one's easy isn't
it yeah it's like it's always like you
hit an oil well
in a lot of ways because all you all you
got to do is turn back and just look
back a little bit
right sometimes yeah six weeks couple of
months sometimes a year or two
but as long as you go back far enough
you can always find something that
was just patently ridiculous uh and the
latest of course we have the cereal yeah
well thanks so much for joining us and
uh just to begin off here i would humbly
like to say that i feel like nostradamus
today
oh yeah we were talking about these uh
i don't know why people call them swabs
they're really probes they go inside of
you three inches uh important talking
point here when when describing what
just happened to the u.s diplomats
[Music]
so yeah i was talking about it yesterday
we were talking about it weeks ago i
said it was going to be expanded i was
talking about it
years ago on my independent media
channel we are change and if you would
like more nostradamus like
content you can get it on we are change
that or go there right now in the top
right hand corner just put in your email
list it is
imperative to keep me alive and if you
want to support nostradamus you could
also
buy my t-shirts like the where one i'm
wearing right now which we're going to
be talking about later in a related
story which you could exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com thanks so
much for having me
and you know me everybody ian crossan
what's up coming at you ian
crossland.net andrew i'm glad you're
here we can report the liberal economic
order i don't know if you're familiar
and the derangement of the term liberty
yes and uh
coerced in a bit but thanks for thanks
for joining man good to see you guys
pleasure's mine pleasure's mine
and then i'm in the corner pushing
buttons for these guys and this is gonna
be a wild conversation hope you guys are
ready for this
but before we jump into the podcast we
have an awesome spot today today ladies
and gentlemen we got virtual shield just
go to surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get 50 off for life a
virtual private network service what
this is is a basic level of security for
you as you browse the internet
we know that there are hackers we know
there are government agencies and
nefarious individuals who want to break
in steal your data track you
spy on you and even these big tech
companies they know everything about you
they know really really weird and creepy
intimate things about you well a vpn is
that basic level of protection
where not only are you locking your
doors and windows but you're pulling
down the shades so they can't see
in you know i i the analogy i always
give is
we don't expect people to break into our
homes but we still lock our front doors
go to surfing internet safe
and you can get like i said virtual
shield at 50 off the link is in the
description below
it's just 2.50 cents per month per month
and you can enjoy 24 months of online
security from the world's easiest and
fastest vpn
for only 59.88 over 77 percent off they
say plus
50 off all add-ons and other great
discounts on their other plans
they're also proud to announce that this
month all discounts are guaranteed for
life that means 50
off for long as for as long as you are a
customer
virtual shield is awesome you guys
they've been a sponsor since i started
doing youtube
literally when i had only a couple
thousand uh i think i had tens of a few
ten thousand
what number i don't 50 000 subscribers i
don't know what the number was
and uh they sponsored my show back when
i wasn't getting that much traffic and
they stuck with us all this time because
they're legit
and i'm eternally grateful so again
surfing internetsafe.com
and don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member for exclusive members
only segments
we did one yesterday talking about lady
lady gaga's dogs getting kidnapped and
how
luke and i were threatening to go john
wick on anybody who threatens our pets
if you want to hear it timcast.com
become a member but let's talk about
this first story
it's a friday night everybody and we're
going to make sure that you're getting
only the best of entertainment
hi brown we were like should we talk
about joe biden and
the nuclear code very serious and then
luke was like we gotta talk about
the chinese shoving stuff up u.s
diplomats butts
and i said i don't know if it's the most
important story in the world but
it's certainly entertaining well we were
talking about the story i mean i came in
here i was like do you guys believe this
is happening and i went off on a tangent
i was very
uh elaborative about it and you thought
this was a joke
yeah i was like i was like man this guy
in his metaphors this is fantastic i
know
it's it's hitting it's gripping on the
cut i wonder what the difference
happened
what was this mainstream media news
u.s official asks china to not subject
their staff
to kovid
behind probes that go inside of you and
of course the chinese response was very
telling at first they were like no no
this never happened i don't know what
you guys were talking about they denied
it
now they're saying oh this was done in
error and we promised it won't be ever
done again
so here's here's what happened the state
department's pissed all right we
destroyed from the hill
state department says it never agreed to
china giving us diplomats coveted 19
anal tests they say chinese officials
who
forced they forced american diplomats to
undergo
bum bum swabs for covet 19 did so in
error
the state department told the hill on
thursday as beijing denies it conducted
tests at all
the washington post reported last week
that u.s officials
had said some american personnel in
china complained that they were being
subjected to anal swab tests for
coronavirus by chinese authorities
this is so obvious what they're doing
they're doing this to subjugate and
humiliate
what they're doing makes no sense
they're going to clone well it depends
uh with what dna from no no no no no dna
from the butt
yeah i think it's part of that i think i
think no no no
no no ian is on to something yeah you're
right because there was official u.s
government sources coming out just a few
days ago
talking about how china was trying to
get the covid tests that were used
in order to get dna samples from
americans so they could
better predictively predict the market
and dominate it in the pharma industrial
complex game
yes i'm not kidding you so china now is
on this huge rampage of them trying to
get as much information
as they can they understand information
is the new oil
they've been on this huge race trying to
get as much as they can because they
know hey
if we get everyone's dna we're going to
know what they're going to get sick of
in the future
they're we're going to know what
ailments they're going to have we're
going to know what pills to make what
medicine to make to sell it back to the
united states at a cheaper profit that
we're going to mass-produce
and we're going to out-compete the other
competitors in this larger pharma
industrial complex so this was a legit
thing that they're talking about
and there's a reason politicians bring
their own toilets when they visit other
countries
the information you could get from your
you know what uh is it
extremely important and and many
politicians
literally i mean there's there's reasons
secret service literally has a detail
uh probably ones with the bad political
opinions but the secret service has a
detail
that that is in charge of collecting the
president's poop
to make sure a foreign country doesn't
get it because if they do
they'll yes yep that's i'm telling you
so this is this is
this is more than just ridicule in my
opinion it wouldn't surprise me if these
larger
uh butt probes were done in a way to get
the dna of u.s diplomats in in some kind
of
larger uh information grab that of
course the chinese will use to their
advantage in their fifth generational
warfare
larger propaganda efforts that they're
in charge of so yeah a lot of this stuff
is real i've been talking about this for
years people have been looking at me
like you're crazy i'm like they're going
into your behinds watch your behinds for
years
you're like oh you're kidding you're
just i'm like i'm not joking
i'm telling you this is coming and this
little the thing
with the diplomats is only going to of
course be the start of this
since they're going to be expanding this
and and other countries are going to
recognize
everyone's dna let's get a fact check
they don't go around collecting the
president's poop
because they're scared of people
collecting it they they bring secure
portable toilets for the president for
security reasons yes
because if the president's like in a
mall bathroom or whatever it's like it's
a security risk
another risk is of course the people
getting information on the president
from
the inside of the poop well well well
luke is correct from npr china wants
your dna and may already have it yeah
i saw that go by yeah they say as covid
cases begin to rise a year ago a chinese
company contacted several u.s states and
offered to set up testing labs
as a byproduct the chinese firm at
beijing genomics institute would likely
gain access to the dna of those tested
the offer was tempting for states
struggling to set up their own testing
facilities for a new virus and short
notice
but u.s national security officials
urged the states to reject the offer
citing concerns about how china might
use personal data collected on americans
quote we certainly reached out to our
partners and the community to make sure
people were aware
that the chinese were pushing out these
tests informing them of what the risks
were
and really asking them not to take the
tests said mike orlando
the head of the national
counterintelligence and security center
which is part of the office
of the director of national intelligence
as far as i know they all turned them
down
so there's actually a bunch of stories
about this they've been
trying to get access to american dna
have you guys ever used those uh
23andme tests yeah it's the same idea
i've never taken them have you guys
have you taken them before no my brother
did recently though so i guess all my
dna is out you're in
yeah i just don't i don't know if it's a
big deal but i don't want to
speed up the process if it might be so i
just haven't no it's a huge
deal this is this is crazy from newsweek
china wants your dna and it's up to no
good from gordon g
chang an author this is from november of
2020 and he says
why does china want such sensitive data
beijing is determined to dominate the
biotech industry
beijing may also be developing
biological weapons designed to target
certain ethnic groups yep i had that
i had that in my list i was waiting to
talk about that because again
we have to understand it's not just the
pharma-industrial complex that's going
to be screwed over if china gets all of
our dna
that's going to outbid them and know
what people are going to be sick of and
know what the demand is in the big
pharma markets but it's also bio weapons
that of course could be used could be
genetically engineered
to specifically go after individuals
with a specific genotype
and only affect them so this is larger
biological warfare stuff that of course
is
is being studied being conducted a lot
of it the united states is paying for
but a lot of it is ending up in the
hands of the chinese which is absolutely
perplexing mind-boggling
and infuriating to find out i mean dr
fauci was literally
responsible and and was one of the
bigger founders behind that level three
level wuhan laboratory inside of china
not many people want to talk about this
but they were doing gain of function
data studies on the coronaviruses
linked to bats specifically talking
about how they can engineer them again
not trying to come up with any theories
here i'm just stating some facts that
were
uh talked about by the us mainstream
media and admitted to them i'm not
jumping to any conclusions but it's an
important fact to understand here that
this did happen i mean new yorker had a
piece
that that explored this concept right
and i think one of the things that we
probably don't give china enough credit
for
is they are evaluating different ways of
fighting asymmetric warfare
of thinking about ways that they can get
a jump on the united states and that's
everything from building new battleships
to exploring the ways that they they can
use biological weapons
exploring the rectums of these
difficulties speaking of exploring yeah
and i'm
tim i'm also with you i think on your
earlier point too because i think some
of this is just a power game right yeah
i'm i'm reminded of how uh during during
the cold war
the u.s state department this is back
when we were tough and good at things i
think
a long long time ago in u.s foreign
policy the
uh the russia desk would only hire
diplomats
from the united states who were men who
were over six feet
because they wanted to make sure that
there was a better chance that they
would be able to physically look
down on their russian counterparts wow
psychology so much of it is
i mean think about it like it's it's
just a giant game of chess
at least to the state as far as the
state department sees the world so much
of it is just a big chess game and so
why not have every advantage
but think about this too like china has
no shame they want to win and they'll do
whatever it takes exactly even looking
in the butts of our diplomats
and i know it's funny but this is
serious too because we wouldn't do that
for the most part
the united states probably isn't even
thinking about having someone open up
you know spread their cheeks and then
take a sample but china knows there's
things we'll learn
and secrets will gain access to by
understanding the diets
the the gut biomes of these people right
and if they can produce some
look we know that like gut bacteria is
very important
what if they're thinking can we craft
something that just is a detriment to
american diet gut bacteria and that
causes americans to become
bloated and tired it's a hypothetical
but seriously there's a lot you can
learn from that sickle cell anemia
notoriously was harming the
african-american population for whatever
reason
it's it's not a it's not a fecal it's
not like a bacterial disease it's a
blood disease it might be it's
genetic yeah so so it's part of the i
think it's part of the blood cell it's
part of the shape of the
african-american blood cell and it is
different it's based on the genome and i
was actually talking i've talked to
people who have advanced scientific
degrees
this is one of those conversations you
can't have but they did tell me you can
design
things that only attack certain genomes
they only attack certain races
this is something china has thought
about americans don't think about it
chinese think about
everything we thought about our kids
with tick-tock they're thinking about
bio-weapons
maybe possibly with covet i don't know
we're not conspiring here but
well the us has been talking about bio
weapons especially with some classified
documentation that came out for
for you know a very long time ever since
the vietnam war uh
now as far as how clandestine and how
overt they are we don't know because a
lot of it is clandestine a lot of it is
something that we don't know there's no
transparency there's no accountability
whether on china they just do everything
out in the open but also with
uh you know you have to understand you
could get someone's dna uh from a no
swap you could also get it from a
behind swab not a swab probe you could
get it from a
butt probe as well so they most likely
now the chinese have a whole bunch of
dna samples on all the us diplomats that
willingly
took their pants off when the chinese
government said take them off and they
did
which is which is i mean just imagine
being a us diplomat and and
just saying yeah sure china here instead
of being like i'll get on a plane and
leave right yeah
right instead of having some like
dignity and saying hey no
no you're not sticking anything up my
butt
like i'm sorry like like like have some
courage here
the us department has to release trust
to the science
that's what it's all about you got to
trust science are you saying you hate
science
[Laughter]
yeah um so science is a big hammer
and if you use it improperly you can do
a lot of harm with it yeah
this is gross it is
and just hear it from their own mouths
they'll be like rocking back and forth
yeah
they don't make water hot enough yeah
and that's the thing too like his hands
are cold
at what point would they just kind of
look to their supervisor or superior and
be like dude do we have to do this
like yeah like at one point with
somebody just like you know actually i'm
we're gonna call back to the embassy
we're gonna check on this one real quick
give us five minutes
what is it like for us diplomats are
they like under the the finger of the
communist party when they're over there
that's a good question
probably not i i would assume not only
because they spend so much time on
american properties right on embassies
and consulates
the interesting thing though this is
something i could have expected from the
american media
because they very much live under the
thumb of of beijing while they're over
there
but you would think that the american
diplomatic core would have a little bit
more
a little bit more dignity a little bit
more self-esteem and a little bit more
of an ability to push back and say no no
we're not going to do this
but listen we're living in strange times
and so america's becoming weak
yes we can it's it's a big metaphor here
it's easy for biden to be like i'm going
to bomb syria because what's syria going
to do about it
and we go up against russia because
russia could fight back to a certain
degree but ultimately
what are they going to do about it china
oh yeah we can't fight china they'll win
and they're winning that's the that's
the scary reality of everything that's
going on and i think so much of it is
they want to see like and this this to
me
more than anything else is they want to
see what they can get away with right
this is
in so many ways this is just a microcosm
of the sorts of things that they're
doing in the south china sea the sorts
of things they're doing in tibet
the sorts of things that they're doing
investing in africa and eastern europe
um this is this is a power play right so
much of this is a power play and it's
how far can we push the big guy on the
block the united states
and get away with doing this kind of
stuff and if we can keep doing this
right if we can if the belt and road
program can run through traditional u.s
allies across africa
if we can muscle our way into tibet if
we can muscle our way into hong kong
why can't we do some uh rear end swabs
on u.s diplomats why isn't that the next
step
it's it's it's incremental it it sounds
silly to a lot of people they probably
don't think it's that big of a deal but
it's just one more grain of sand making
a bigger heap where china says we can do
whatever we want
we can go to an american and say take
off your pants and bend over right now
and they'll go yes sir
yes no problem sir when i first heard it
i think yesterday maybe you brought it
up yeah i just know
i was bringing it up yesterday i heard
about it i was looking at the sources
like we need to confirm this yeah yeah
as we were talking about this a few
weeks ago a few weeks ago we were saying
hey china has developed a new way to
test for covid and it's going up your
buttocks three inches
to swab you and i'm like this is not
what you think it is it's coming uh it's
going to be expanded
and now here we are today sorry it
almost like washed over me yesterday i
was just like oh well
whatever i'm not surprised but
they lied about it they lied they lied
about it big time that's really a big
deal man this is bad
no it's it's it's it's a decay it's just
like everything seems to be heading down
into the into the into the crapper
yeah literally and figured that's right
that was hard to say yeah
well no no i was gonna say and so much
of this too
is it's it's china stepping back and not
just pushing to see where they can go
but
to forgive the pun but probing where the
weaknesses are
right where are the vulnerabilities
where are the places where u.s diplomats
aren't
don't have a levelhead about them in
terms of the decisions they're going to
make the power that they're gonna
that they're gonna stand up against and
the things that they're unwilling to do
and i think
the more they do that i wanna use it to
jump to the next segment we'll talk
about the weakness of the united states
so we have this story that came up a
little while ago from military.com
dozens of house democrats call on biden
to give up soul nuclear launch authority
this is crazy but it shouldn't be uh it
shouldn't be unexpected
joe biden is he's not all with it
that's fair to say there's been reports
that kamala harris has been doing his
job for him because he's been
napping in the sun as i predicted yeah
she's talking to foreign leaders on his
behalf or whatever
and now they're saying we we think joe
biden should give up soul power to
launch nuclear weapons
and you know what i agree i agree i
don't think a senile or crackpot
should be holding nuclear football give
it up to who to open it up to other
people now that's a problem
who are who are these other people maybe
you know what
this is this is the problem of having
you know a president who's in
only because people hated the other guy
you know they clearly right now you've
got all the democrats complaining well
not all of them sorry
all of the progressives complaining
about biden some of the democrats
but many of them just saying biden can
do no wrong right
you get a president who's based on
hating the other guy you
and and he's basically what's the
difference you know a lot of people say
like
you know he's going to do a lot of the
same foreign policy things actually
doing worse people are worried now we're
going to lose this piece we're
developing in the middle east
he's going to destabilize everything but
i'm sorry he is he is a senile old
crackpot
who was elected without the ability to
be president and now democrats are
saying he should give up
the sole power of the nuclear duty just
bombed syria well
okay let me just get this out really
quick i don't know much about this
bombing of syria i read some mainstream
news articles from nbc and some other
and they were like
it's in retaliation to iran okay
obviously nbc is going to say that the
other one was
oh this might this is actually a
perverse way of improving diplomatic
relations with iran
because it's going to be forcing them to
the whatever
it's sickening i'm sorry well so let me
read some of the story from military.com
they say nearly three dozen house
democrats are urging president joe biden
to relinquish his sole authority to
order the launch of nuclear weapons
arguing that no single person should
wield apocalyptic military power
they say vesting one person with this
authority entails real risks
past presidents have threatened to
attack other countries with nuclear
weapons
or exhibited behavior that causes other
officials to express concerns
about the president's judgment according
to the letter which was spearheaded
by california reps jimmy panetta and ted
liu now interestingly
nancy pelosi tried doing this with
donald trump
and i believe it was what like after
november yeah she went to
the joint chiefs i believe and she said
block trump's ability to order missile
strikes and they said ma'am that would
be a military coup we can't do that
the commander-in-chief has the ability
to fire the nukes
they're taking this away who would get
it it sounds to me
like look it's gonna say as cliche as
possible
all of these things are just ripping
this country into a million pieces
that's it well you know i never agree
with politicians
but these politicians make sense when
they're when they're talking about
one person on this earth that has the
power to press one button
and end the human race i'm sorry that's
a little bit too much power
when we're going to be engaging in
nuclear war we're engaging in a war
that's going to end
civilizations as we know it and i agree
with these democrats i never thought i
would say this but i agree on the merits
here
i don't agree uh i do i think it should
be decentralized i think definitely
there it shouldn't be one senile old man
who doesn't know where he is half the
time sometimes so that's
that's a problem of joe biden but then
the issue is you're creating
exponentially more vulnerabilities with
each individual you'll give the ability
to press a button
let's put it this way you've got joe
biden as a senior little crackpot and
that freaks me out because he might
press the button and fire and knock they
said
donald trump was sporadic and erratic
and he might press the button and launch
a nuke that's still only two people
add 10 more people and now you got to
keep track of each and every one of them
who might launch
a nuke it'd be cool if you needed all of
them to agree well i think that that's
that's my question too is what is the
no that can't work either is the
alternative that we have just a bunch of
different
checks and balances if you will before
you can fire the nuke because
if that's the case yeah i guess i guess
that makes sense but if you start truly
federalizing the nuclear launch codes
and really start having that many
hands in the in the kitchen here's
what's gonna happen the chinese
communist dictator you know xi jinping
is going to be like
i can launch all of the nuclear weapons
and they will have no time to retaliate
we win we win china will succeed
our cities will be fine and every nuke
will explode over america before they
even realize it i guess you could
automate a defensive response
and only you know federate the the
offensive line to like six people that
need to agree and turn
at the same time no but the issue
anything really convenient about just
having well maybe so there's a reason
why we have a president
who is the commander-in-chief it's so
that we can respond quickly and
instantly to serious militaristic
threats
well maybe just add one more person
that's sound mind that's next to him
so this is the problem so what they give
us a crackpot president and use it as an
excuse to disseminate
a bunch when we gave the president the
power like that we didn't have
world-ending weapons true no wait we did
not create the nuclear weapons we're
like mr president they're yours when we
created the office of the president and
gave them all that executive power we
didn't have nuclear weapons that could
end the
human race so the problem is unless you
can answer me this
when china and russia know as autocrats
they can snap their fingers and blow up
the us and we can't respond
what defense do we have i don't think
biden could respond anyway it'd probably
be sleeping i know
i know you need to you need an automated
response better by giving more people
the launch codes
the problem is we are in a very
seriously dangerous position
because joe biden is a pathetic senile
old crackpot
i'm being a little hyperbolic no you're
right he's showing the cracks in the
system
so now you've got vladimir putin what is
he he's former kgb right yeah yeah and
he's riding on a horse with no shirt on
yeah
and he's he's so brutal i mean look at
the the dude who's trying to run against
him gets poisoned all the time yeah
all the time this guy is probably
laughing his ass off like
joe biden yeah what is he gonna do it
really does beg the question of
if we don't trust him with this with
this responsibility of a president right
cause that's all like
we can fight about who who's it should
be but um if this is a
a dually charged role of the president
and we can't trust him to do this then
what else can't we trust him to do
right in what other settings does he not
is he not someone we want to be
presidential
if we can't trust him to be the only one
with his finger on the trigger for the
nuclear buttons do we trust him
one-on-one in a room with xi jinping
or with putin yeah i i mean again like
these like
and again you know as soon as pointing
out the people who know this
want to do us hard well this is the
thing the vulnerability is there whether
it's two people or not because of joe
biden
i made the shirt that i'm wearing right
now months ago and it says i'm joe biden
and i forgot this message
this sentiment was true months before
the election
it was true every time he got on stage
there's a reason they kept him in the
basement
there's a reason he didn't do many
public speaking events he does a lot of
gaffes he messes up a lot of the time
sometimes he messes up the locations
where he's actually
in yeah and that's extremely concerning
for the man that literally has his
finger on the button and could end the
world with one i want to click
make an observation it's not biden it's
a problem it's the
cognitive decline of the human brain
that's the problem and that's going to
be no matter what
yeah what's cyber biden you need to get
elon musk to neural link
yes just give him a tune-up could you
imagine
has an image of this yeah so the
paintings you guys see on the walls
behind everybody
is uh george alex atlas and one of his
one of his memes is biden sitting in
this chair with like
a electrode helmet attached to his head
and he's like drooling as children are
being fed to him
it's a real piece of art it's hilarious
right but uh i'm kidding we're not going
to make cyber biden but it is a good
point
the ultimate problem i see with this is
this this office is important and
powerful for a reason right
you have congress they legislate they're
slow
and nobody likes them they're not meant
to respond very very quickly
when we're being attacked the president
can declare a state of emergency and
make and take unilateral action
and that's their excuse for like bombing
syria which is dumb because syria's not
doing anything to us
the problem is they hated trump so much
that they were like we would rather have
listen let me stop they said when donald
trump
got elected you know there's a lot of
republicans saying you're attacking the
pilot of the plane because you don't
like the way he talks over the intercom
you're gonna make the plane crash
they hated trump so much because he's
flying the plane
he gets to the intercom and he won't
shut up and you're like just
stop right right so that so then some
doting you know some dotard
is sitting there drooling all over
himself and like i want him to fly the
plane
and now they put this sleepy creepy joe
who's sitting in the pilot seat drooling
at himself sleeping in the planes going
yeah
and like falling down and they're like
better than the guy yelling at us for
you know the entire plane ride and
right he had two brain aneurysms my
goodness i mean
i i i is
yeah it's just utterly insane also the
timing of this is is very important
because this letter came out right
before
he unilaterally decided to launch
airstrikes on
syria right of course without
constitutional approval without
congressional authorization
and according to many illegal under
international law but really just
continuing the policy that barack obama
codified
in 2014 and just bombed another country
without any kind of oversight
transparency or even accountability it's
for natural gas
biden says no keystone pipeline in
america but you know what they're doing
pipeline in syria yeah see it's it's
okay
when foreign contractors go and build
gas pipelines in other countries that
were blowing up
not okay when american workers do it and
it's kind of like you know i mentioned
this before
they love outsourcing jobs they love
outsourcing factories
and then they don't want any of it here
it's almost like a not my backyard thing
oh we want the oil we want the gas but
not in my backyard even from a pipeline
right that's the other thing too this is
the richest part
yeah i know it's it's insane and like
listen it it's gotta hurt of all of the
people who it probably stings for the
these strikes it has to hurt the worst
for nira tandon
who famously said that we are going to
attack libya to take the oil
and now she is seeing us attack syria
for no good reason and she's probably
like her eyes are probably lighting up
with dollar signs at the very thought of
it yeah
and yet her confirmation is going to get
railroaded because she's uh
because she tweeted a bunch of really
dumb things yeah that but also like
she's
like by all indications a bad person she
punched a reporter one time which i
don't think you're supposed to do
um and perhaps one of the one of the
most awful things
even if you just look at it through the
way that the dems see the world but i
think the way that we all see the world
too
is she um in an all staff meeting she
outed one of her employees at cap when
she worked there at the think tank
for bringing charges of sexual
harassment against their boss
and so as they were as they were talking
about it she just outed this
this private concern and complaint um
the people the people who are who are
look man the federal government is just
a swamp yeah
and and there's like a tiny handful of
people who are stepping through the
swamp that are okay but for the most
part
it's a swamp trump did not drain the
swamp the swamp is just murkier than
ever and joe biden's back in and he is a
swamp monster yeah and think about it he
was
like he's got so many people that he's
inherited
who are former biden or obama alums
yeah and they're like what have they
been doing for the last four years since
they left the obama white house
or well that or they've just been making
a bunch of money
working at working in washington and so
they've only gotten more swampy right
they've only cycled out and now cycle
back in
we also have to acknowledge the fact
that three last
sitting presidents bombed syria without
any congressional uh authorization
the last time donald trump did it uh jen
sackey tweeted by the way in 2017
quote also what is the legal authority
for strikes
assad is a brutal dictator but syria is
a sovereign country
g gen yes of course he is joe biden even
tweeted that trump was erratic impulsive
and it's the last thing a
commander-in-chief should
should do when of course donald trump
bombed syria because his daughter cried
this is the end
ivanka's uh ivanka trump cried to him
and told him to do it after the alleged
chemical weapons attack which there have
been some very serious questions about
and a lot of evidence countering all the
information but the big thing here we
have to understand here
is when donald trump bombed syria there
was at least some kind of
fake attempt to frame some kind of
evidence they tried they did it very
poorly it was it was fact checked to be
wrong
but now there's no there's no evidence
where's the information
where's the wmds where's where's the
justification for this that allowed the
united states to do this they usually
put on a horse and pony show
right before launching another strike
they didn't even do that this time
they didn't say there was a threat they
didn't show any evidence they didn't
highlight anything that that could have
justified this
we still don't know let's jump to uh
this thread from drew
this one guy democrat hypocrisy but i
want to start by saying this ladies and
gentlemen
this is the end what we're seeing the
utter hypocrisy from democrats and media
pundits
cannot survive progressives
are already tweeting smack talking the
democratic establishment in the media
establishment
obviously not every single one but many
of them are saying we did not vote for
this
there's one there's one twitter account
that's getting memed around like crazy
because they were like
i'm deactivating my account i did not
realize biden would do this this is
wrong
we didn't want war he lied to us i think
about barack obama
he did the same thing but there was no
twitter right
so what happens is we can see the
hypocrisy
we can see jen sackey press secretary
saying under what authority is donald
trump bombing syria
what about now when joe biden 36 days in
does the same thing
we can see all of these democrats and it
is it is
stamped in our mind so what happens now
is the younger generation
yeah they're going to see these tweets
and be like yeah these people lied
that's it
right war is bad we don't want this i
say this at the end what i mean is that
the establishment stranglehold
and ability to keep lying is weakening
i'm optimistic in this regard yeah
because
it is you know i've asked how was it
that so many people still fall for the
mainstream media they're probably older
people watching tv
younger people aren't now many of these
younger people probably fall for garbage
emotional manipulation from
a lot of these leftist grifters but
let's pull this thread we have
from the man himself drew holden and uh
your tweet reads
it seems not all pointless foreign wars
are created equally
in the eyes of the democrats the media
and the chattering class when trump hit
syria was an outrage
but under biden well apparently things
are different do you want to just read
through some of the tweets we'll show
them and yeah
break down for what you found i i will
so i i was going through it today and i
i looked and i saw a lot of the
uh i was reminded very quickly of what
happened in 2017 and 27
2018 where there was enormous criticism
of donald trump hit syria i'm sure i was
probably critical of it too
and i was like yeah i'm not sure i'm
well about this one like i criticize i'm
getting these people tweeting at me
and they're like the haters the
tribalists and they're like are you
gonna
do you know criticize biden no you
wouldn't criticize trump and i was like
i i did i criticized trump on the syria
thing like every video
people complained about it you get it
tim you're mad at trump for firing
tomahawk missiles into syria and i'm
like yeah
what am i gonna i'll complain about it i
i've supported tulsi kept yeah exactly
the tribalists are full of it i lost so
many followers when i went after trump
for doing those moves he's like no
trump's doing the right thing i'm like
no
and i remember calling him out
aggressively and losing a large ton of
followers and i was like i don't care
uh goodbye and they're like you you're
like cnn uh
you you're trump braceman syndrome i'm
like no i have principles something a
lot of people
you know so what you discovered so what
what i found very quickly was that
for whatever reason all of the people
who were incredibly critical in 2017 and
2018 uh were not
critical or the best one i think the one
that i started off with so usually the
way i structure these is
i'll hit the uh the members of congress
first and then the media and then
whoever write blue checks
but the first one i had to start it with
this is a phenomenal side by side it's
lawrence o'donnell of msnbc fame
when back in 2018 he had tweeted dear
news media
if you think trump has constitutional
authority to attack syria please say why
if you're not sure please ask the
question please stop using the phrase
constitutional crisis
as it can only refer to firing people
not missiles right
a lot of concerns very concerned with
lawrence o'donnell then
lo and behold yesterday last night right
after all this goes down
he tweets out a link to his upcoming
show that has ben rhodes
failed mfa uh a failed short story
writer
turned uh policy wonk apparently ben
rhodes and
lawrence o'donnell tweets ben rhodes has
been in the room when
the president orders a proportional
response and he has them on and they
talk about why
this this specific attack made total
sense complete in total sense well you
look drew you you just misunderstand
it is always it has always been the
position of the democrats that
bombing syria is a good thing now the
issue isn't that donald trump
was bombing syria the issue was that the
man who ordered them happened to have
been orange
it makes sense now yes it's a night and
day difference and so i think
it's interesting because a lot of
democratic politicians very much went
with that sort of mentality and thread
my favorite nancy pelosi she tweeted
this is
in 2017 so right after these first
strikes retweet if you agree
which is a horrible thing to put in a
tournament right
in terms of a little twitter 101 please
for the love of god don't do that
retweet if you agree that congress has a
responsibility to immediately debate
president trump's actions in syria
which is hysterical because back then in
2017
she had no power to bring everyone back
in and
force everyone to have this conversation
she is now the speaker of the house
who could call back congress tomorrow
she could force them to have this
conversation
for whatever reason no interest weird
but perhaps actually i take that back my
my favorite among elected officials has
to be barbara lee she used a couple of
uh
a couple of emojis i think it's
questionable it's dubious
the first was the shouting emoji all
capped trump doesn't have the authority
to have troops in syria much less to
protect oil
apparently biden does and then again
twitter 101 please don't do this
producing foreign oil clap hands is clap
hands not
clap hands ay clap hands legitimate
dance military
clap hands mission clap hands just do
the clap stop endless
protecting foreign oil is not a
legitimate
military mission stop endless war thanks
i hate it
like no follow-up from her for whatever
reason maybe maybe i shouldn't turn on
the news i don't know because
friday is often not a working day in
congress so maybe just hasn't hurt did
you try to contact them be like hey do
you have a do you have a point on that
i should well so obviously i always tag
these people whenever i tweeted them and
for whatever reason i haven't heard
anything back on those ones oh
strange what is this a proportional
response to
there was there was a rocket strike on
an iraqi uh military base yeah
that killed an american contractor so
joe biden said
oh i'm gonna blow him up allegedly
that's what they say
right we have to understand what they
say is usually a lot different than what
actually happened and
yeah and and and more importantly there
were reports going around as soon as
biden got in that u.s troop movements in
syria started escalating
and we saw western news sources saying
that's not true it's a myth that's this
is totally normal
and then we saw you know middle eastern
sources saying the us
is running troops through syria yeah and
then
the new york times i believe had the
best take today they had an article that
was titled u.s airstrike in syria
targets iran backed militias
in that article it literally says and i
quote
little is known about this group
including whether it is backed by iran
what literally that's yes that's
literally what they said so again
a lot of information is very sporadic
it's very hard to believe
a lot of anonymous government sources
are coming out and they're not putting
their name behind this but they're
saying this was defensive wow
anonymous government source new york
times yep little is known about the
group including whether it is backed by
iran or related to organizations that
use the facilities
for uh the american air strikes targeted
on thursday let's go right to the top
of the title yeah u.s airstrikes in
syria target iran-backed militias
they are lying clap clap clap down
right right yeah and this is it and it's
already and this is the thing like you
in a lot of ways the media can speak
these sorts of things into existence the
new york times had another story
with strikes with strikes in syria biden
confronts iran's militant network
yes i saw that right it's the same thing
it's if you repeat it this is this is
wmd's all over again
if you just repeat it over and over and
over again it becomes part of the
conversation
another big thing to realize here the
iranian forces in syria are the ones
that are partly responsible
for crushing isis al qaeda and al-nusra
and other
sunni radical groups uh the iranians are
basically shiite groups
that are fighting against the sunnis and
if it wasn't for the iranians and the
syrians working together
isis would still have a huge foothold
inside of syria so
by biden and by donald trump attacking
the syrian government they're attacking
the people that are stopping isis
that's spreading radical jihadism and
terrorism all over the west
that's another point here that you know
oddly that point was forgotten by the
mainstream media they forgot to mention
that one for some reason
under trump isis was crushed was that
correct yeah i think so yeah well they
lost a lot of their funding that was
given to them by barack obama and
hillary clinton
and then he blew up the the main dude
yeah yeah yeah well russia also took a
large part in that and exposed how a lot
of the oil that was being uh
you know siphoned in by isis was
actually traded to turkey
russia exposed how there was caravans
working with the turkish military along
with isis
usually financing terrorism saudi arabia
israel also financed the sunni larger
wahhabist terrorist groups in there
israel by the way was given advanced
notice of this airstrike
and they released the statement that
they're very pleased that this airstrike
happened in that particular region
so there's a lot of different
geopolitical things happening but
essentially
i boil it down to the larger class of
civilization civilizations that's
happening in the middle east between the
sunnis and the shiites
the sunnis the radical islamists are on
the side of israel so
they're they're saying in the media over
and over again iran ronnie ronda round
around around deep down they say oh we
don't know for sure but we're gonna keep
saying their name over and over again so
how long until we have war with iran
i mean they've been they've been trying
to do this john bolton said what did
john bolton say
by this time next year we will be
celebrating in tehran he was wrong on
his timeline but we have to understand
what syria is it's not about syria syria
is a larger proxy war between the united
states
russia and also china in some ways china
has actually even
sent some support to the syrians china
has a very close relationship with the
iranians so does russia
so there's probably going to be another
proxy war just like we're seeing in
yemen
just like we're seeing in syria just
like we've seen already play out
in um in libya that's going to take
place in iran but another big thing to
really kind of calculate here and
understand this larger web
that the military industrial complex
paints to you
is the fact that it was the fir it was
the gulf war
after 2001 in 2003 when the gulf war was
launched
that made iran such a powerhouse
in the middle east region because it got
rid of one of their chief competitors
iraq and their sphere of influence
actually grew they became more powerful
because of the war in iraq so again
these
neoconservatives literally created the
boogeyman and we could even talk about
the cia coup
in the 50s and and all this other stuff
but but the the fingerprints on the
military industrial complex on the
neoconservatives
is literally create the boogeyman let's
finance isis let's make iran more
popular in the region
and let's go to war with them next
they're literally creating their own
problems that they're now coming to you
and saying well we have to
you know we can't give you that 2 000
check we can't give you 15
minimum wage we got this huge threat we
got a fight that conveniently
we made happen and and that's the big
lie sold to the american people who
just conveniently keep forgetting
american history
i'm doing clapbacks
but i'm just absolutely flabbergasted
and so disappointed in people especially
in the mainstream media
that don't talk about these events in
relevant
uh timelines that actually give people a
perspective to see what's happening here
because
we are essentially paying for the
destruction of this country by putting
us in these quagmires meanwhile china
they're having our lunch they're they're
probing our diplomats and they're going
to
going to be doing a lot more with their
global hegemony which they're going to
take over with their policies
rather than our self-destructive hurting
policies that put us in debt
and send our american troops into harm's
way for what we've got we actually have
uh
breaking news we have exclusive oh yeah
an exclusive photograph of joe biden
actually making the switch between
giving checks to the american people and
dropping a bomb and as you can see he's
wearing a leather jacket and
a what is that fedora is that a cool
door
yeah and uh and he's he's got a swap
that doesn't have a check
for the for the missile very quickly
indiana jones thing yeah
that's what happened you know what you
know what's really sad
i'm not mad i'm sad all of these twitter
accounts from these progressives who are
like but we thought biden was the good
guy good
but you thought it was a good guy all
poor baby at least they're waking up
listen i'm not i'm i'm annoyed i don't
want to be mean
we i think we're old enough to where we
experienced the obama years
we knew what obama was going to do or we
knew what obama did we knew what biden
was going to do
and we kept saying it over and over
again and they're like yeah but trump is
a fascist
okay well you know have more war i guess
we're going to go to war with russia
let's see how that plays out that's the
next big trump was a fascist
any than any other president that's not
a fascist well this country's fascists
no it has it's built on the backs of
slaves and corporate
corporatocracy that's fascism no it's
it's suitable for us
but you know it's basically controlling
the world through military coercion it's
not fashionable it's attempting to
there's a there's a lot going on in the
world it's not like dictatorial fascism
no you're using fascism as a general
term for life corporations have been
dude raytheon ceo is now our defense
secretary is that what it is
yeah that's crony capitalism it sure is
but we're allowed to talk about it it's
not fascism well it's not
like it's not totalitarian fascism it's
just like
fascism was the fact that they're not
coming in here are kicking our door and
then you know probing us
it's just that we're not but if we if we
allow these people if we allow these
people to keep doing these things
eventually
it will be yeah it's especially under
joe biden it's it's a it's an
information war
you're right and it doesn't have to
happen in iran if as long as we keep the
communication going and keep people
aware
that we should not be going into iran if
these bombings are out of order then i
think we won't go well another thing to
kind of add here just really quickly
is the fact that china's taking over the
world through trade we're taking it over
through military blunders that indebted
us forever and that's not achieving
anything
iraq wants us to leave syria wants us to
leave there was an iraqi parliament
that literally voted please the united
states leave the united states decided
not to do that and not to listen to
a direct government order by the iraqi
government
and that's that's when we had these
mysterious kind of rocket attacks
that somehow or justifying our our our
bigger involvement in there i'm not
putting on any theories out there
i'm just saying it was very convenient
of a timeline that did happen
you guys want to talk about
authoritarianism you don't talk about
fascism you'll talk about all that stuff
how about this story from ctv news
man charged with assault at montreal
quarantine
woman says she felt helpless you don't
get you don't get enough of
understanding from this headline
let me tell you what happened a woman
heard they were going to start
instituting mandatory quarantines in
canada
she decided i'll go back to canada now
before they do this took a covet test
when she arrived and said that was the
wrong covid test so they took her to an
undisclosed location
a hotel they told her she wasn't allowed
to tell anyone where she was
where the hotel was or what was going on
and while she was there a man sexually
assaulted her
this is authoritarianism this is what we
have to worry about with
with these passports with these
lockdowns i watched a video
it was from rebel news i don't know
don't know a whole lot about it but i
saw this video on twitter
and it's a it's a one of their reporters
is walking down the street filming
probably my assumption is he was filming
like this is what the lockdown looked at
looks like you know i'm out here showing
the people and the cops gave him a fine
and said we don't care they wrote him a
ticket curfew for an adult man
walking down an empty street now listen
i mentioned that
that's not the worst of it this story
was sent to me
and at first i was like what is this a
guy's being charged sexual assault at
montreal quarantine hotel women says she
felt helpless what is this
and she said she felt helpless at a
hotel where she didn't expect to end up
and where she was told she wasn't
allowed to disclose her location quote
they didn't tell you where they were
taking you
which is unacceptable they gave a set of
rules can't post on social media
can't disclose location federal health
officials told ctv
they're aware of the incident and taking
it very seriously the assault
that's what they care about to the rest
of these people it's normal that this
woman was flying back to her home and
was
apprehended by the authorities for
breaking no crime told she couldn't tell
anyone what was going on
she couldn't report anything on social
media she couldn't give her location out
they brought her to an undisclosed
location where she was assaulted
what th this is insane they're literally
taking
people who have broken no laws right
locking them up it's also
and the problem with all of this too is
it it's the case in canada i'm sure it's
certainly the case in the united states
when you empower government to do things
right we've seen this with a patriot
actually
there's lots and lots of things when you
allow governments to have
lots and lots of power and lots and lots
of authority that is relatively
unchecked
against everyday life and against
everyday civilians they don't give them
back quickly right we've
the coronavirus cases are down like 75
77
i think in the last couple of weeks
right and despite that has your life
changed has
have any has anyone's life changed be
fair we're in the middle of nowhere yeah
we don't yeah that's a good point you
guys
say i i live in dc and so it's a whole
oh it has another universe
nothing's changed everyone's wearing
people are wearing two masks instead of
one now that's the only thing that's
dropped of all the razor wire and the
yes yeah yeah yeah i i went for a run
the other day because i used i used to
run and i'd run up
up to the cap because i lived pretty
close there no i mean it's it's
it's as if we're living it's like east
west germany it's insane but
what happens when government gets these
powers is that a
bureaucracy that is empowered to make
these sorts of decisions is always going
to think they are going to make the
right decision
they are not going to give you the power
and authority back and it has been i
think to me really incredible
despite the fact that the cases are
falling and deaths are falling
life isn't actually returning to normal
in all of the places where all of these
lockdown restrictions have been put in
place and what is and canada obviously
is a nightmarish example of this
but we're not that far from this kind of
no we're not and what is fauci saying
look if you go get the vaccine nothing's
going to change
you'll still have to wear two masks you
won't be able to go to the movies or go
out to eat
so go get it anyway and people are
actually not questioning that why would
they do it
who's going to do that and here's the
thing too like listen if all he would
say it blows my mind because all he
would have to do
absent this power conversation if he's
someone who just wants to see people get
the vaccine you know what you do you
tell them how great the vaccine is yeah
we have managed in the span of a very
limited amount of time
to come up with a revolutionary virus
because of the power of american r d
in research that can vaccinate
evolutionary vaccinations
that can stop and shut down a pandemic
that has brought the world to its knees
go get it it's safe we've tested it a
gazillion times go get the vaccine well
the long-term tests
haven't been done yeah it takes a while
yeah i i
i don't want to get into that another
thing i wanted to bring up is before
you know forcing the the strictest
lockdowns the canadian government also
disarmed a large public of the canadian
citizenry and we had politicians like
justin trudeau that was
in october of 2020 telling its citizenry
don't believe the conspiracy theories
that there's going to be government
quarantine camps it's a conspiracy
theory don't believe it
it's not going to happen and here we are
today when you enter canada it's not a
camp
it's a sheraton hotel
of course corrupt security guards that
do unspeakable things to you
and i mean i mean this is just
it's just it's like the frog boiling
yeah that's essentially what's happening
here
and there's still a lot of legitimate
questions uh surrounding the vaccine
that i do believe should be asked uh
from my own personal opinion
yeah you would think that with like a
kind of like a propaganda campaign in
favor of the vaccine that people like dr
fauci would be
super raw raw about it i don't know
trump did it he's not
trump did it and they're they don't like
that's it that's it that's fine i mean
look
we mentioned this before all these
stories were coming out saying like oh
boogeyman vaccine a doctor took a
vaccine two weeks later was dead
and then i read the stars like wow what
happened and it was like he had a stroke
oh two weeks later he had a stroke okay
come on i'm concerned about the
the the the you know the speediness at
with which this vaccine was put out
there
but i'm worried that there are the same
nasty unethical journalists who are like
it's trump's vaccine though
you know let's rag on it let's let's i
mean
and the politicians certainly like the
power so i i'm i wonder why it is fauci
is saying these things
maybe he's being honest maybe it really
isn't that effectual or he doesn't know
well there's yeah maybe
maybe they did it because they were
scared and people needed hope so the
vaccine is worthless is that what fouch
is saying well again this is
rushed this is still experimental and
there have been some findings saying
that if you do get the vaccine you could
still spread the sickness there's been
studies saying that there's been experts
saying that i think even
you have to look this up correct me if
i'm wrong i think even fauci said this
himself so
uh when we're looking at you know i
don't think this is trump's vaccine this
is
pfizer's vaccine this is modernism this
is johnson and johnson's vaccine and it
was operation
speed that trump streamlined the process
to ramp everything through really really
quickly and provide massive funding for
all this
guarantee but when people look at it now
they don't see trump uh
that's that's the point that i'm making
here yes trump played a key initiative
uh in in pushing this vaccine uh but the
questions about its efficacy and its
safety
those still are kind of questions that
are being asked
and we'll see yeah and and dr fauci is
the one who's basically undermining
confidence in it
yeah and that that to me is is insane
yeah
and like and to me again like at the
risk of being a little bit black
helicopters on this stuff
i think part of it is if he were to go
out and say that it is fully effective
and fully safe and everyone should get
out and do it
then people would probably start stop
looking to the cdc for advice
right like if you look at all of the
different things that the cdc recommends
you do most of us ignore them on a
day-to-day basis
right how many like how many people
truly go and they're like well you know
i really like the taste of medium rare
steak but
the cdc says you have to cook it to at
least a medium no one people don't do
they really say that yes that's one of
the recommendations
and i think it's like it's like it's
like one or two drinks is the maximum
like they have all of these like
they have a litany they have a litany of
very very silly rules that no one
actually follows this is foreign
they're telling people to ruin their
steaks yes exactly
who do we impeach the thank you thank
you but here's the thing
right now we right now people are it's
in a lot of ways it's like the weather
men when they predict storms right
as long as they keep telling you that a
storm is coming you're gonna be glued
you're gonna pay attention
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the weather
channel and see if it if we're gonna get
six inches or eight inches or 12 inches
or is it going to be worse is it going
to be nothing but if you keep saying ah
something bad and scary is coming around
the corner
people will keep tuning in i mean and in
his case people will keep empowering him
and the rest of the agents of the state
to be able to say oh sorry you can't do
the things we don't like
it's an addiction yeah you've got people
who have power and they've found a way
to use government to gain more power be
it money
shutting down all our competition and
allowing only us to remain open we're
not going to oppose that
and so unless there is a principled
individual to snap their fingers and say
stop this which there isn't right why
would anyone give this up now listen
the people running the big box stores
and the big massive you know
uh online stores who are allowed to stay
a lot of stay open and are making all
this money and
making billions and billions of dollars
they're gonna be like well look it's not
us it's the pandemic so we're not gonna
get involved i think elon was pretty
good about being like
things ridiculous i'm not shutting my
factory down i'm leaving california
come with me he needs people driving
their cars yeah so i'm not trying to
impugn in the honor of elon
but if people are staying home they're
not buying cars they're not driving cars
right so it's good for tesla and it's
good for their bottom line when people
are out and about
you look at amazon it's the inverse they
need you in your home waiting for that
delivery
so why would they resist in any capacity
these politicians are also thinking
i got a guaranteed salary and everyone
is sitting there terrified
and will do whatever i say sounds good
to me yeah
if people lose their livelihoods who's
going to buy teslas so that's another
thing to really consider here as well as
on the other hand we did had a job john
hopkins doctor recently come out in the
wall street journal
journal op-ed and write that kovid's
going to be over by april
we had the independent reporting that
there there has been no influenza cases
in the united kingdom all year
there also has been a huge influenza
drop in the united states
and according to english health
officials and the deputy chief
medical officer of the united kingdom he
is even saying
as of two days ago that face masks may
not even be necessary by the summer so
this is also happening
as well as the same time as we're
discussing that's what fauci's you know
dark
predictions and dr fauci's opposite
viewpoint
of what all these other medical
professionals are saying in other
countries did you say there was no
influenza in the united kingdom yes
according to the british
the the uk health records there was uh
zero cases of influenza of flu in the
united kingdom this year 2021.
let's uh let's talk about this not a
single case of flu detected by public
health england this year as covetous
restrictions
suppress virus experts say decline in
infections
could justify continued use of hand
sanitizer and masks following
chronovirus pandemic
that's really amazing that kovid was
skyrocketing while the flu is
disappearing yeah you trying to
fact-check me there ian i want to just
point this out good i like that i like
that we should be fact-checking the
influenza
is being is present but they're not
classifying it as an influenza infection
instead they're saying it's a covariance
well we don't know that no we don't know
that i'd like to investigate that
but it does raise an important question
similar uh
numbers have gone down in the united
states so there's another article
uh that i was just reading a couple days
ago about influenza almost totally wiped
out in the united states there
still have been some documented cases
now now again we don't have the evidence
it's it's a stretch
to to go there but but some people are
going there
but again this is something to to think
about this is something to add to our
calculations when we're
looking at the sphere of our current
modern day
the flu when people were staying home
couldn't spread
but covet could but it wouldn't mean
that you wouldn't get it like yeah it
would slow the spread but that doesn't
mean it doesn't exist it's interesting
what i had heard in terms of the
influence of coming the united states is
that there's essentially and
someone's got to fact check me on this
but i think the argument is that
influenza the annual influenza tends to
come from central and south america yeah
uh and that every like it it cultivates
there for whatever reason right and
don't forget the
the seasonal flu we get now is just a
dilapidated version of the 1918 spanish
flu
um and it just it never quite went away
and that's kind of how they assume that
it keeps community too
right and so every year we get like a
slightly like a slight variance
on a new strain and for whatever reason
my understanding is that i don't know
where it starts but it tends to come to
the united states from central and south
america
since there's a lot less tourism there's
a lot less immigration i think the
thinking is that it it hasn't actually
kept
its normal course so you're saying that
migrant caravans are putting out
we have to lock the borders down but
there's one argument that's only i'm
only half kidding i mean that's
that's true too like if that if if the
flu is really coming from
you know a lot of these people then
border security would help prevent a lot
of these
i do think it's about i think it's
mostly tourists though i think is how it
it tends to work but also interesting
point you made earlier
is about this wall street journal op-ed
which i read the other day i found
fascinating
and basically the crux of his argument
is we're not taking into account how
many people
already have a natural resistance to the
vaccine because there have been so many
asymptomatic cases i think his estimates
are that
there have been between five and six
times as many people who have been
infected by coronavirus than our numbers
have
not for any malicious reason but just
because um a lot of people were
asymptomatic had it never got tested
never even thought to get tested never
even knew they had it yeah of course and
never knew that they had it
and so um the when we talk about herd
immunity one of the biggest factors is
that in the case of this op-ed the
argument is that one of the biggest
things we're not talking about is
how many people have natural immunity
and so if instead of
a million or a couple of million it's a
lot higher than that
then you don't actually have to
vaccinate as many people until you get
to a point where the numbers continue to
fall and continue to fall to a point
where they're almost vanishing yeah most
of them by the way have healthy immune
systems have good vitamin d levels again
something that we should be talking
about more
there was also another uk study that
talked about how the vaccine won't
eliminate the virus risk
i think it was also in the wall street
journal that reported this as well which
was kind of interesting vaccine won't
eliminate
virus risk i think was the title i don't
know if you're able to find it or pull
it up there
but again there's so many different
things being
thrown at us that we have to understand
all of this is extremely
complex a lot of the experts contradict
themselves a lot of the mainstream media
reports sensationalize it make it as
hyperbolic make it as fearful as they
can for you
and a lot of the real legitimate things
about your health your immune system
sleep stress proper diet exercise
vitamin d sun a lot of that gets missed
again not a medical doctor not a medical
professional not telling you how to live
your life not telling you what to do
but i'm just saying that this whole
conversation around this from the very
beginning has been toxic has been
polluted
and has been politicized so that people
take advantage of it for their own
personal benefit and sadly
our politicians did that to us let's
talk about solutions
yeah what does a regular person do
well the next story we have is from
washington times five
oregon counties to vote on leaving the
state and escaping to greater idaho
understandable and they actually have
two phases the first phase
is to get these five counties which
would turn idaho into a
coastal state it would give them a port
no joke no
way i know it would reach the the uh
pacific
i love it they also have phase two which
would rope in
northern california yes into greater
idaho
it would not create a new state and this
is this is their plan
so you have all these counties in oregon
which are conservative the organ
these counties are saying the
politicians in in
in portland in oregon they're they're
all democrats right it's all the
democrat areas right they dominate the
state politics
and they're giving covet relief to their
constituents in ignoring the rural areas
the rural areas say well we got more in
common with idaho how about the idaho
border move and encompass
us i like it
one one of the challenges they say is
have you guys heard of the state of
jefferson
yes northern california same thing
they think they should break off and
form a 51st state called jefferson
because they have nothing in common with
the rest of the state in the big cities
and they do not get represented the
problem is creating a new state
california is going to have to sign off
on giving up this territory the u.s will
have to have like a
article 5 convention whatever it's
called where like all the states come
together and then vote for amendments
and that would create the new state the
same thing is true for greater idaho but
it would not change the amount of
senators
so there should still be the same amount
of congress men and women
and there should be the same amount of
senators and all it would do is move
some borders around which they say
does happen i'm a fan of i'm a fan and
you've got
sovereignty away from of course the big
socialist communist
very far leftist governments and and
super populated right i think
one of the big problems with northern
california is that it's more sparsely
populated it's more rural and so
not only are they going to be ignored in
terms of their political disposition
like they just don't have the political
capital
to be able to get the the people who are
making the decisions to care about them
right and with greater idaho obviously
that would that wouldn't be the case you
do have so much
surely so much more shared value and so
much more shared interest
i guess it would change the the house of
representatives for each of those states
presumably if enough people shifted and
moved but
you're right it wouldn't change the
number of senators and it probably like
california will lose what maybe one
congressional district at most and so
yeah i don't know i think i think this
is such a great idea to give a voice to
some of the more rural populations i'm
so i don't know about you guys but i'm
super tired of the big cities having all
of the concentrated power
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah and
so this one people need a voice
so the interesting thing is that there
was a study that came out recently that
said even in
red states the cities are blue yes yeah
the issue is that in these blue states
the cities
are disproportionate in population size
to the rest of the state
in the red in the red states it's
inverted so
it'll be interesting to see all of a
sudden these counties that have zero
representation
all of a sudden feel represented that's
great i think it's a great idea because
what's the alternative
yeah exactly people if people feel like
the government does not represent them
what do they do yeah this country was
founded based on that fact peacefully
it's a great thing about being in a
democracy like this too or republic
representative democracy is you can
alter your borders peacefully
yeah here's the weird thing we've got
weld county colorado right
yes they want to be a part of wyoming
for the same reason you got the state of
jefferson
even if the people who live there say we
don't want to be a part of this place
anymore and we're the ones who live
there
we are the people who run this county
the state can still the state still has
to vote on whether you're allowed to
leave
yeah that makes no sense to me i don't i
don't think that should be why would a
state let you leave yeah
why would why would they be like we
willfully give up people who are tours
yeah exactly exactly these are taxpayers
who have no representation
who are funneling money to their
salaries and of course they're not going
to let their serfs leave
yeah exactly the problem where those
people end up doing they get angry
you'll see protests they'll we've got to
have representation
it would be interesting to see if that
like just as a as a phenomena catches on
right forget like those individual
places for a second
if individual communities can say hey
look
we share we are a hundred feet away from
another state that shares our values and
we are existing within a state that
doesn't
what are the sorts of things we can do
and animate to start to move and change
those things
um i think you could have that could be
a really really fascinating experiment
in federalism to see how that plays out
at a
all across the country look at how the
democrats want to make puerto rico and
washington dc
states so they can get four more
senators yes and then have a uniparty
contr a single party rule controlling
the country now
to be fair the republican party
establishment democratic party
establishment essentially the same thing
but what what's happening now is the
democrats don't even
want to bother with whatever you know
pseudo arrangement they had in the first
place
and they're like hey we'll make two more
states and then we'll never lose ever
again
right they would tell you oh jefferson
can't become a state
that's ridiculous why it would create
two new republican senators
or maybe not i'm not confident what's
gonna happen to the republican party
i'm seeing all these these progressives
saying like joe biden
bombed siri instead of giving us checks
good luck in the midterms and i'm like
they don't need it the republican party
is split in and is fractured
right people they want trump they want
people who support trump they do not
want the crony establishment
so look we've had people on this show
who have mentioned the idea of peaceful
divorce yeah i think luke's mentioned
peacefully
my the first time i came on the show i'm
like hey don't don't don't make fun of
me but i think memes
and peaceful divorce are going to be the
only solution that are going to cause
the least amount of harm
on people so if you want to reduce harm
you're going to have to work out a
solution where people peacefully move
away from each other and decide
to live next to each other and not
aggress against each other
well without a peaceful divorce like how
do we get to that point right
right and so i think we're seeing what
recall
efforts we're seeing a lot of people go
after the governors and complain about
them
but we always try to vote out incumbents
and it doesn't change things for a lot
of people
that's why so many people who never
voted for voted before voted for trump
right
because they're thinking what's the
point it's not going to change anything
going back and forth well then someone
comes along and says i got an idea
how about we move this town to a
different state okay that sounds pretty
good
so five counties are going to be voting
on this
in may apparently in november several
counties voted
to do it already not that i think it
will really happen
but they're saying we want this right
all right the states and the federal
government say
no you can't do it well these people are
i mean what happens
because i talked about this before when
you know joe biden or fauci says here's
our new
you know coveted guidance and this town
says we've had it yeah
no and they set up their own checkpoints
they said their police say we won't
force this
already we're hearing in many
jurisdictions the the sheriffs are
saying they're not going to enforce
that stuff what happens then when these
people feel like without representation
i have no confidence in the system
anyway
in this in the in the state of jefferson
i'll do air quotes
there are people who have flags for the
state of jefferson
they want it they demand it i guess in
the end
what we're seeing here is this will
start heating up and then eventually
you'll get to the point where when this
fails people say peaceful divorce
yeah i mean mr the mr potato head thing
was enough to get mark dice to say
time for
what's the plan with mr potato head now
not to diverge too far away are they
going to come in potato
you just made you just made a very big
mistake oh boy he called the potato
potato mister potato
it is now just potato head no now it is
just potato head or potatoes
before it was mr and mrs potato head
it's genderless
and now they're just both called potato
heads yeah are they both genderless or
is it just
they're both the same potato but mr
potato head comes with like eyelashes
and big lips yeah
and the mashed potatoes comes with the
mustache oh but it's just all gonna be
packaged as potato head now
yeah like so now you get i guess one
with everything in it sounds like they
might like
not now now they don't have to make
different color boxes yeah with
different designs they'll save some
money on design and box production yeah
but then it sounds like they're going to
be selling less products
what if you did like mr potato head mrs
potato head potato head kids
yeah we had potato heads potato head
yeah you can't do enough
you could have i mean you could take a
dog a non-gendered potato head
you could do a blm potato head you could
do anti-fat potato head
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
we're giving away really good ideas i'm
telling you i think i think what this
all was
as soon as i saw it at first i was like
well this is dumb and then my second
thought was
oh no there was some really creative
intern who said i can get potato head
trending
and his bosses are like yeah okay yeah
potato head hello this has brought
potato head for a good journey she's
like listen follow me here
potato mr potato head no gender do away
with it
watch what happens boom now we're
talking you know the worst part was
when he was like he was a pitch meeting
where the intern was pointing to like
his slides and like as he's pitching the
the the
no gender mr date head the other intern
was walking and holding the ipad with
potato dick and potato boobs
and then he hears he overhears him
saying it and he like you know
we've been making states since 1776
right and so
why don't we just keep making them yeah
well making states is hard
because the the political process around
it is tortured right the whole
forever there will always be a
democratic push to make washington dc a
state
the argument will be the argument will
narrowly be we should do
like the implicit argument is we should
do this because we need to enfranchise
everyone
because they want two senators
republicans will make the opposite point
say hey this doesn't actually make sense
in the constitution
but fundamentally don't get me wrong the
whole from a uni party perspective
if it would have been two republicans
who got elected senators i guarantee you
that a republican party would find a
really compelling reason
why we've been misreading the
constitution the democrats would be
saying the constitution they would be
saying the opposite thing and so
you'll always see that back and forth in
that fight about new states the
important reason we have dc is not a
state is so that the federal government
exists
outside of any state's jurisdiction we
have to have that puerto rico actually
actually makes sense to be a state yeah
me too but and like if but imagine if
you could look at
uh god i don't know what you would call
it between it was a jefferson state the
state of jefferson
if you could have the state of jefferson
and then part of oregon and say all
right here
this has like if you could cut out those
areas and make them have approximately
the population of puerto rico and say
all right guys one for one we're doing
it
yeah okay yeah i think that'd be great i
don't think the dems would probably not
go for it only because they would lose
some little bit of representation and
all of that and and california obviously
drives so much of the modern
party but i don't understand the logic
behind
i'm not being represented in this state
so we are going to self-govern
and them saying but we can say no how
does that make sense
the constitution is literally you know a
government of by and for the people
you know it is the duty of the people
blah blah blah all that stuff so what's
the justification now for the us
they're not leaving the country they're
not leaving the union right greater
idaho
is is crafted very politically in a very
smart way to say oh yeah it won't change
the amount of states
it will give idaho more representation
more uh congressional representation
actually no i don't think it would
actually change the break the makeup of
congress because the jurisdictions for
congress are not
are are are going to be based on like
the sort of county level
right well so they'll be based on the 20
it's interesting in terms of when it
happens it'll come down to the 2020
census but no
it's a population question and so it
depends on how much how many people
greater idaho adds to current idaho well
so
the the area of oregon that is going to
break off and join idaho
already has a republican representative
these districts oh good point
so they would join idaho it wouldn't
change yeah it would just mean that
state law would benefit them they'd be
able to have guns they would get their
coveted relief when they need it they
would be respected or represented is
very smart what they're proposing that's
a good point
i think it's a huge problem that oregon
can be like nah
well you're not representing their
people if they come to the federal
government and say
we object and we demand the right to do
this i think the federal government
should say agreed yeah i think so too
if idaho agrees idaho is the only one
who has to agree to this
the counties have to agree and idaho has
to agree oregon should have no say in
the matter look tim
it's there's too much common sense for
the government to do this ah
yeah so if if it was ridiculous stupid
and counter-intuitive
they would have their stamp on it right
away exactly right but but it it
this makes a lot of sense this makes
perfect sense if we
lived in a just society where we had
government that actually served its
people
it would happen but again we have to
also understand that the government of
california the government of oregon
a lot of these bureaucrats view their
citizens as tax cattle and tax slaves
so they're not going to want to give up
people who they're going to be able to
tax and take a huge amount of money for
that they don't have to do anything for
so the initiative of the government
that's already going bankrupt especially
in california that can't balance a
budget
that that can't that has so many
wasteful spending
bills and initiatives and programs that
are just absolutely ridiculous
they're not going to give away their tax
slaves they want them just like
just like in in ancient days with in the
roman empire they saw people
as money they and and the people were
converted into slaves that's the same
thing that's essentially
serfdom yeah this is this is like a
neo-feudalist kind of thing yeah
these people with no representation are
paying taxes and that is money the state
will not give up now here's the funny
thing
when the the greater idaho people said
covet relief went to
the democrat constituents and not us
that's your money
yeah that's the money from the
conservatives who paid the taxes and
then saw
that tax revenue from the federal
government and from the state level go
to
their political rivals and was not
fairly allocated so would it have to be
that idaho buys the territory
from the other states no it's like
reparation for the
loss no i think it should literally just
be
we live here we vote for the land the
county says
the the council members whatever
represents this county yeah we are now
idaho
but california could be like well we
spent a lot of california citizens taxes
to make those cities
what they are so you owe us something
before you leave
that's something that we need to be
adjudicated that's the problem what the
people in greater idaho are saying is
that they're not
getting that they're not getting the
resources and so the argument from
someone in like portland was like well
you're gonna have to consider all the
taxes you've got to pay and they're like
the taxes would go down
yeah we would pay less in taxes i know
and you're not giving us the resources
so the problem is
the grievance they have is you're not
investing in us
you're not fixing our infrastructure or
giving us the coveted relief we've asked
for
you're giving it to your people who are
going to vote for you to maintain their
power
that is going to lead to conflict in
crisis
when one side is getting too little and
one side is getting too much
it's the hunger games yeah so what makes
sense
if i live here i should be able to be
like we vote
there we go the land is this county
idaho what do you say
then idaho would have to vote right and
if idaho says yes
done yeah exactly and that i think in so
many ways too
that would help get around concerns if
you have these places that aren't paying
much in taxes that aren't super valuable
you would at least have to have buy-in
from the places they're going to say
yeah they're not just taking them in as
you know as as the back straggler or
what have you these are just
people who we want to break bread with
and so we are going to do what we need
to to legally empower them to be
citizens like us do you know what
happens if you do not
respect the people you get this story
right here from the independent
lady gaga dog napping fbi
investigating political motives singers
dog walker was shot and our two french
bulldogs were stolen
they're essentially saying check this
out the fbi is reportedly investigating
if there were political motives behind
the dog napping of lady gaga's bulldogs
after she sang at president joe biden's
inauguration last month
the pop superstar is offering half a
million dollars for the turn of her
french bulldogs koji and gustav
who were stolen at gunpoint at a gun
point a gun shot
but luke you see a lot of people might
say what political motives you mentioned
something earlier
about this yeah i remember seeing some
kind of form of entertainment where this
was a plot line of going against the
bourgeoisie and stealing the rich
people's dogs as form of like a cultural
warfare i don't remember
exactly what i couldn't pinpoint when we
were talking before the show that's why
i tend to bring it up now
uh but but you know i i think there
might be a bigger political motive
potentially here i think it also might
be
motivated by crime that has been spiking
in many big cities that is going to go
dramatically up as of course our
economic woes continue
well they're saying the fbi thinks there
may be a political motive right yeah
but i wonder in los angeles is that maga
country
i don't i do not believe it is huh so
could it be
some fringe leftist saying eat the rich
these people i think these people knew
who the dogs belonged i mean you got to
assume that they did right like the
other thing too is they didn't just take
the dogs they shot the guy who had the
dogs and then they took the dogs
so you've got to assume i mean my hunch
is it's either it's either for ransom or
yeah like think about where she was
i'm saying i'm saying this my initial
assumption is this is crazy for the fbi
to insinuate
that's nuts okay it was probably some
guys who were like yo it's lady gaga's
dog shoot that guy take his dogs
but if the fbi has reason to believe it
was politically motivated i don't see it
as being right-wing
first of all oh definitely not
right-wingers going around shooting
people and stealing dogs does not make
sense to me
no it would have to be like if there's
anyone who's gonna do that and i think
it fits the reason we all jumped onto it
earlier is it it fits the the class war
narrative i think in the democratic
party of
if it's anything it's probably something
from like i don't know a communist
revolution that happened in china or in
russia where that's what they did to the
wealthy and
like as a form of punishment they took
the items that they had
that conveyed some sort of class status
right yeah it's no different than
stealing someone's range rover today and
so it's
like that's that to me if there is any
political intonation it has to be that
yeah i'd be curious at who in the fbi
is saying that they were kind of
investigating this i'd be really curious
what they were thinking the motivation
was because they're you're right there's
no chance that this is maga country
because this is
la that ain't maggot country it's even
less so than it was in chicago when
jesse smilet was dealing with it oh poor
man
um but uh these dogs are very expensive
and i feel like everybody knows that and
i think that this is probably just
crime honestly and i guess this has been
kind of increasing
so i don't know i mean they're like two
thousand dollars yeah
[Music]
but even i mean in this special
technological surveillance big brother
state i don't think
people would do ransom because they
would get caught right away
uh with so much metadata i mean facebook
knows everything about you
this is why the political thing i'm i'm
questioning yeah look
look i would not entertain this normally
but the fbi is investigating a political
motive over this
and they're saying it's because she's
saying it saying it biden's inauguration
but that's kind of like
the far left was planning on protesting
hillary clinton's inauguration as well
back in 2016 and then it turned into a
trump protest
they don't like joe biden and like luke
said what ransom are you gonna be able
to get from stealing lady gaga's dogs
okay maybe they didn't know as lady
gaga's dogs
maybe they saw a guy with dogs and said
yo but i don't believe that because
these dogs are extremely valuable
yeah they likely knew where the dogs
came from they likely knew what kind of
dogs they were
they had to have known it was lady
gaga's and if that's the case ransom
would never have worked so were they
hoping to then get the reward
later from lady gaga or sell them
because they're worth a couple grand
i don't know but the fbi says political
motive and i don't i don't
look to a bunch of maga guys you know
definitely not with some bleach and some
uh
tracking down this guy yeah and there's
more expensive things to steal right
like pursue like if you were
if you were in downtown l.a you got to
assume there's probably like
cars watches right like things that you
don't have to hold for ransom you can
just resell
it's fast i also do think it's like
absurd to think that some like antifa
people were like
eat the rich and then they shot this guy
and stole the dogs you know what i mean
yeah
so yeah is the fbi just reaching here
imagine being the fbi person
imagine imagine like you're an agent and
this comes across your case you're like
i'm sorry
lady gaga's dogs this is what i have to
do today
yeah no no there's an fbi agent and he's
sitting in his desk and he's like super
ripped and he's like
his suit's about to rip you know his
muscles are so big and then they come
and they're like
agent johnson it's lady gaga and he goes
don't tell me her dog and he's like i'm
on it
and then it plays the theme song the dog
bounty hunter
i love it or it could be just two
dumbasses that just randomly decided to
be violent
because there's a bunch of violent
dumbasses mainly in big cities
and then the fba is like i can't fix
this i can't solve this let's just play
politics like we do everything else yeah
exactly because they always do that it's
like how well might as well be right
yeah
let they announced that they found a a
length of rope
tied off in the back of lady gaga's car
and they're like oh
yeah it's interesting a subway bag i
think was also
discovered nearby wow that's gonna be
the meme forever for all these hoaxes
having a subway sandwich
i mean it's like it has to be it also
just like okay i am i'm reminded of what
what happened often because it is just
so fundamentally ridiculous and people
ran with it remember i think she deleted
the tweet but kamala harris tweeted
she's like
she's like i've never known someone as
honest and as brave as jesse smalling
these people are
they just crazy it's like i imagine
kamala harris is sitting there
and you're like miss harris what's your
first name
and she goes harry
i can't tell the truth i have to lie
you're like tell me just something
simple fact and she tries really hard
john yeah because it has to be a lie out
of her mouth
i wonder every single one of these
people if because uh gaga
performed at biden's thing that joe and
kamala know her
and they think that the fbi will get
more funding if they say that it might
be politically motivated then just
solved it
interesting the two people who stole the
dogs was joe and kamala
that's what i'm getting at it and it was
joe with the gun he's like yeah
come on man get the dog do they get more
internal funding if it's a political
crime yeah i don't know i i think of the
the kamala harris meme where she's like
looking on the phone and looking down
and everyone was like
everyone's saying she's on the phone
with joe and what she's saying to him
and i think of her going like joe they
they found the dogs
[Laughter]
they know that it's us the gig is up no
but but you do bring up a good point
in that uh they just attach white
supremacy to everything
yep you know so if there's like a
problem so so like you know
a dog got kidnapped and the fbi can't
figure it out i do a white supremacy
and then the left goes that explains it
and they go oh thank you there are two
fbi agents for that fake news
fake news yeah that's right yeah yeah so
we're getting to the point where like
you know someone's car breaks down
and then like the he brings in the shop
and the guy looks at and goes uh
white supremacy yes and then the guy
goes oh
can you fix it well i'll do my best let
me see if i can get the adl on the phone
out here it'll just be an excuse for
like anything that goes wrong right
it's like the power will go out and then
people will be like we won't know where
the power is out in the mirror bag
ladies and gentlemen
hate crime white supremacy that's it and
they'll be like what
like that's what happened and they'll go
help us please
help us oh heavens that's big cities to
be honest yeah i was sort of saying like
i'm pretty sure this is what they're
doing in
was it la or another city there's been a
spike a purported spike i don't know if
the numbers are actually pretty solid
but
there's been a purported strike in
anti-asian american violence
and i saw someone blame they were like
well naturally it's white supremacy
they protested for this yes new york
city they did a march against white
nationalism
and the suspect who attacked this asian
guy was black white yeah
and then and in san francisco the same
thing yep it was a suspect was black and
they were like but it's white supremacy
right
that's what driving dude new york with
with the attacks on the hasidic jews
all the time it's the same thing it's
like this is this is white supremacy run
rampant again
wow these people are insane that's one
of the reasons i want to be in the
cities anymore but look
i'm not we mentioned it periodically
throughout the show but like this is
just
falling apart when when you have
very clearly a black man attack an asian
man
my response is i don't care about the
race yeah it was a guy who committed a
crime
but then when all of these people are
like white supremacy was the problem and
they go march i'm like yo it was it's
it's
listen it's class it's poverty it's
education like we need to
to to help these areas not scream like
i'll tell you this i'll make i'll
simplify this okay i'll just slow down
if we see crime regardless of race and
we say
if we can alleviate poverty by targeting
class issues
and you know economic factors and
education then we can help solve that
pr problem of violence instead of doing
any of that they go it's like you know
you know that meanwhile throughout the
meeting
and it's like the one the two two people
get a really bad one and then the third
guy gives it looks
saying and they throw out the window
yeah yeah yeah so it's like there's a
guy who's part of the table we need to
do something with all this violence and
then someone says
you know like we can blame white
nationalism we can blame trump
supporters and the third guy goes
we can just help deal with the poverty
that leads to violence
yeah it's easier for everyone to be like
how about we just
uh march against white nationalism and
solve no problems
bingo because it's it's like the other
the problem is
the alternative is you have to slog
through the hard stuff right you have to
work through
the education and like the psychology of
criminality and all the other difficult
things
family yeah and all of these other
systemic
problems that there's not a there's not
a silver bullet for and there's not a
convenient bad guy for
that sounds like hard work exactly and
you gotta target compound interest which
undercuts the elite class of fiscal
giants they're making
100 billion dollars make you a year in
just basic 2.3
interest putting in the right
investments meanwhile i love that i
can't remember which comedian said this
but he was like when you're poor
they they charge you money right like
you're you you go to the bank
and you're you're you're negative so
they're like i got to charge you 35
now you're negative 50 meanwhile when
you're rich they're like ah sir you're
wealthy let me give you
some more money that's the way the
system works is it
like i understand the idea of interest
the bank uses your money for loans or
whatever to a certain degree it's
fractional reserve it's a weird system
but like punishing the poor right that's
just
ridiculous it it was always weird to me
when i would get like an overdraft fee i
like at one point where i when i was
like i was like 18 or 19
lost a bank account because it went
negative and i couldn't stop the
negative continuing to go negative
and i just told him i was like you
realize like i don't have money right
that's why it's negative they're like
well sir you know there is a fee
what happened was it was like uh uh if
you have less than a certain amount you
get
a fee and that fee put me negative and
then i got over
and then i got like a negative yeah gum
or something they told me 35 bucks
i had like four bucks in the account but
it was a five dollar checking fee
because i had under a certain amount so
then it went negative then they charged
me the fee for being negative and i
showed up and said i don't got 35
to fix this duh i was like i didn't know
you were gonna charge me right then and
i'm poor
and their and their response was well if
you don't pay by next week you can incur
another free and i was like then close
the account
congratulations and yeah what are you
gonna do you're gonna try and get 35
bucks for me i don't have
i'd be i i'd have like negative two
dollars and then i'd buy like you get a
pack of gum and then you go get a
sandwich and then you go
buy like a 99 cent some and they charge
you 100 90
35 35 35 separate you call them and
you're like hey
i didn't know i was in the negative i'm
gonna deposit some money and they're
like
i can get rid of half of your charges
you're like dude you can get rid of all
of them
yeah but if you act like a jerk they
won't help you at all there was this
crazy thing that happened in chicago
like 15 years ago with chase bank where
it was there was an error in the atms
and it wasn't subtracting money from
people's accounts
when they were withdrawing from atms and
so it led
so here's what happened though so i go
to the atm
and it was like me and my friends were
all going going to a show like a bar
venue
and i put in my car and i had a couple
hundred bucks and i was like i'll take
out 20 dollars
i see the amount i take out 20 bucks i
look at the receipt and it says the
number didn't change i'm like that's got
to be wrong so i
i'll take another 20 bucks i took
another three bucks the number didn't
change and i was like what what is this
so i put my card back in and then i was
like i'm gonna take out 100 bucks 100
bucks
comes out and i got 140 bucks i look at
the receipt it didn't change and i went
this is messed up so i deposited all the
money back and i got
20. no no no no no because i'm like dude
there's a business they're going to get
you
they're gonna yeah yeah i'm not playing
games it was an error and i thought i
thought it was going to give me the
correct readout but it wasn't so i just
deposit put the money back in here's
what happened tons of people
started being like oh free money yeah
and then what happened the next day
the system updated everybody was
negative like 100 200
bucks and then all the fees and
everything else and the bank was like
too bad i'm like did they do that on
purpose
because they just like imagine you do
that all the poor people think now's my
chance to get some free money because
the system is broken
no it's not it'll fix itself they
just because they they don't know
because the the amount in your account
is wrong doesn't mean they don't know
how many times you took money out
right so it updated and then said
withdrawal 20 20 20 20 and then people
were just like
i just lost all that money yeah dude you
said you went
with your friends to a bar venue i got
really nostalgic oh yeah
really i want to go hang out at a
bahamas
i mean we have one nearby you can go
hang out yeah but not with the mask yeah
i don't want to do this outside i just
want to go chill with like 50 people in
a bar
yeah get an ipa look around at people
so i did that last weekend oh where this
is the first i think this is the first
time i've said this out loud at least
out of like my
apartment with my girlfriend yeah so
here's my public confession
um i i went to nashville last weekend
wow i visited my brother who's down
there
and he was like he he's thinking about
moving down there and so i went down and
i was like listen
i haven't seen the guy in a long time
we're super super close and i was like i
want to see him before not
and i was available this feels so
wonderful
i have people like for the first time in
a year i had people physically close to
me and i was like
great step on my shoe bump into me like
give me a hug man this is
fine i don't i don't mind this at right
this is one of the reasons why i was up
in new hampshire during the summer and
spring because yeah it was normal life
up there you know
large parties large gatherings and and
you know
one of the lowest sick rates in the
nation as i say and no one told the
coronavirus in new hampshire because for
whatever reason
their rates lagged way behind everyone
else in the country
well how about we uh jump over to them
super chat already if you haven't
smash that like button seriously it
really really does help because the
engagement is just fantastic
lets youtube know that you really do
like the content but don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
leave us your comments jump in the super
chats while you can go and start reading
those
and go to timcast.com to become a member
and get access to exclusive members only
content let's read some of these super
chats
all right let's see what we got here we
got petty this one's for you ian
he says ian were you aware that jp
morgan sang the titanic
which was actually the olympic not only
as an insurance scam
but in order to kill three bankers who
were opposed to the federal reserve and
seized their assets
i don't know if that's actually true i
read that before but i think it might be
a conspiracy theory oh
yeah i've never heard anything about
that that's amazing ian's giving this
one a good good google yeah
yeah i haven't been able to confirm them
yeah i haven't looked into it we have we
have a very important factoid here oh
black lion grunt says tim fun fact did
you know that mortal kombat is the
reason the rating system for video games
exists
i missed the i missed the quarter wars
in the arcade
was it because it was too bloody yeah
yeah they were like we got to tell
people they're like we have to allow
some way for parents to know that they
shouldn't give this to their children
particularly the spine ripping out of
scorpion i think is fatality
i mean yeah as the mainstream media was
playing that again and again saying how
bad it was
over and over i remember seeing that as
a child being like why are they showing
it then
we got uh rook says the golden trump is
a troll
we will never stop as long as the media
cries we are electing trump again
period it is trump or nobody trump or no
vote period
i completely believe that yeah it's
quick
listen say whatever say whatever else
you want about it we're gonna do the
golden trump for the oh cool okay yeah
we gotta talk golden trump but it's
gonna be special and we're gonna swear a
lot so
yeah 375 shooter says eric weinstein
stated on lex's show wait until
everything is connected
history is producing rhymes and repeats
via incest
what does that mean though he's just
he's a big picture guy i think once
i don't know when everything wait until
everything once we can see the system
what's happening clearly you know we
have the great reset we've got covid we
have
the federal reserve the finances all
this stuff the war is all over
the energy systems fusion's on the
horizon mars is becoming
like what we're going to see we're going
to look back on this and everything will
start to make sense the ancestral
thing's very interesting too you know
humanity is very ancestral as a species
i'm glad you have to spin anything in
front of you
turk oh yeah um turk longwell says tim
us folks who have fired weapons
understand the damage
not these politicians we need more
veterans in office love the show
spin that thingy can you can you see it
on the camera i don't think so let me
give a little spinny though
you pull it back nothing in it no you
can't you can't see it no matter how far
back you are all right here i'm gonna
lift it up
maybe tomorrow maybe monday the
levitating little flower pot has now
been
decapitated yeah it's over disabled
totally right though we absolutely need
there was a really bizarre comment today
from leader mccarthy or i guess no
longer leader
minority leader mccarthy about um not
having guns on the capitol premises and
listen
i didn't grow up around guns i came to
guns pretty late in life and i know i'm
not alone
among the republican party and and being
that way but it really read like someone
who has always just
sort of thought of guns of being very
icky and i think that it's very
difficult for a lot of republicans to
recognize that the vast majority of the
conservative movement
does not see them that way but i mean
the interesting thing about guns is that
even
there's a ton of support from democrats
for guns yeah so like there was that
moment where the union working guy like
questioned biden on his guns yeah you
also have
you know blue states up in the northeast
they're very pro-gun yeah vermont
it's it's only these like ultra urban
coastal elites specifically
that are anti-gun and they have a lot of
political power a lot of money to push
these things like bloomberg for instance
yeah it's far more a conversation too
about class and about location and so if
you have if you have people who
are poor and rural their feelings of
guns regardless of their politics are
going to be far more supportive than
anyone who lives in a city yeah
we got remy says nukes should be
centralized we don't need politicians or
bureaucrats handling it
they can't even give covert relief
without arguing for months
every major city would be a radioactive
wasteland before we could send a
response
interesting i'm sympathetic to that
honestly like
if there's anything that government is
good at it's not making a decision
particularly fast
yep josh mabry says tim you're right on
the nuclear side
i was in missile maintenance in the air
force the whole point of deterrence is
mutually assured destruction right yes
if
if xi jinping says we fire the nukes
then biden
will fall asleep and then we die but the
idea would be that you fire the nukes
you know so yeah exactly
in theory joshua sanders says each nuke
requires two keys to turn simultaneously
to launch
by not having access to launch all the
nukes i think is just a metaphor
huh metaphor for what interesting i
don't know well i think that's that gets
to the point about
what his like what are the sorts of
steps that the people around him take as
a result of him not necessarily having
the mental capacity that he needs to
execute the office of of the presidency
and so today it's nukes and in a few
months that's who knows and are they
saying that
it takes two turnkeys so like biden
can't wake up in the middle of the night
be like oh and turn the key
no that's the second person to do it
with him i think that's different i
think that's there has to be an operator
there
right who physically transacts on doing
it but there's one person making the
decision
yeah all right let's see
america 76 says people should start
saying obama instead of biden
the okami cabal is in charge of his
administration biden is a figurehead
puppet and the republic is toast
well then jesse padilla says tim i
worked with a syrian refugee that
praised trump for bombing the syrian
government and was happy to be living in
america
interesting yeah i'd buy that advent
falling says tim we're mostly in
agreement if not i respect your point of
view however
gtfo ed and eddie represent libertarian
capitalism
at his freedom double d is innovation
and eddie's ambition
yes fail often teaching us to balance
the eds inside us all i hated that show
they were losers are these the super
chats from yesterday no
no you were talking about members we
were talking about that yesterday yeah
potato masher says luke you are
forgetting about the kurds and the
uh peshmerga i'm not i know about them
and the united states back them and then
turn their back on them when turkey
attacked them and now the situation gets
more perplexing
that sounds right yeah brighton klein
says would you guys consider having tom
mcdonald on the podcast
viral rapper against woke mob ps love
the website i laughed when i heard tim
cuss for the first time caught me off
guard i love your work
oh yeah we don't we don't show on the
family friendly version the bonus stuff
is for the adults late at night
sprinkles with the a word tonight
thanks y'all it'd be funny to have an
episode of the where we custom up but
it's all beeped out
and then have someone go in and put
strategic peeps randomly to change the
context of everything unnecessary
censorship
we were just talking about mcdonald
before the show he's a big hit around
here he just released
clown world yeah so great music video we
are going to have him on
he's fully invited and he knows this and
we're going to make it happen
nice well at some point right yep it's
going to happen
full mental alchemist as you should
never give government any power
what we need is a real reset as in a
divorce very interesting
yeah okay saying it for years andrew
rontas had started listening after
michael malus who was on cash cab
was an amazing alex jones whisperer i
love the nightly convos plans
on a member's audio rss for the bonus
content
so uh so to luke and the best shout out
to luke and thebestpoliticalshirts.com
oh thank you very much
we're working on a mobile app for the
website and then we're going to have
over
ott it's called so that's like amazon
and roku and all that stuff
so then you'll be so then members will
actually be able to watch the bonus
content on their tvs
it just takes time to build so like
putting together the first iteration of
the website
was not super difficult you know you get
a person to like put together the layout
but then getting the actual core coding
and development and apps and everything
is actually going to be a
much longer process but we needed money
to do it so we had to start a website
and then once we got a bunch of members
i was like okay i'll start improving it
yeah
and then we're gonna do a lot more i
mean this app is gonna have other kinds
of content
we keep saying over and over again we're
gonna go to the range but then you know
luke
luke didn't come to the range so how
dare you how did what's true
we ran headless family
[Laughter]
says give biden the thinking cap from
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy oh yeah
i mean that would help definitely yeah
that'd work
j
he is an ex-counter narc agent from
mexico he's got great insights about how
cartels will become a bigger problem in
america in the future
reach him at edsmanifesto.com definitely
indeed we will
we will note that down he's in my mind
dan dante dantic vs
says been following y'all for about a
year now thanks for preparing me for
2020.
luke's video with wesley clark was
shocking heard you guys like rpgs ever
heard of rifts
bebop is my second favorite anime you
think that video shocking
when you watched it imagine being the
interviewer with wesley clark and seeing
his face and being like
oh boy i'm probably in trouble too uh so
yeah that was pretty uh
yeah i've never heard of rifts have you
no i haven't i've heard of it
no i maybe have heard it i started
playing gentian impact a little bit what
is it
it's uh it's a newish game open world
rpg i think it's online i haven't played
enough to tell you too much about it but
it's like very anime style
kind of like breath of the wild in some
ways we'll see i don't know if i'm going
to be into it and actually end up
playing it valham's pretty good
yeah yeah it's development survival
viking there's five people that's got up
to four million views in four weeks or
so
four million users so seven empire says
none of us are virgins the establishment
has
funked us all by cardano what
what's cardona i think it's another
privacy cryptocurrency i've been hearing
about it
made by the same guys that did oh geez i
don't want to mispronounce it ada is the
company that yeah that does it um
where they did they were involved with
ethereum i think i don't know to be
honest i'd love to get their developers
in here though
i mean i've been seeing people tweet
about it let's read some more about my
friends don't forget to smash
that like button and subscribe fox [ __ ]
says fascism is a form of far-right
authoritarian ultra-nationalism
characterized by dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
strong
regimentation of society and the economy
interesting
wait i want to clarify on cardona i
think ada is the token right cardano is
the company is that right okay yeah
tyrell wilson says for my stakes as long
as it's still bleeding and moving then
there it is i could not agree more
trying to get away
yeah chasing it down and you jump on it
some people steve rogan's buddy did you
ever
see meat eater where they all went
hunting together yeah they would he like
kill an animal cut out the
the gullet and like eat it raw eat the
liver raw all right
yeah crazy it's very funny i remember we
were talking my girlfriend and i about
how like the human body has
can no longer process meat because that
was just a thing that i thought was true
totally not true you can eat raw meat
yeah yeah yeah i stick to that all the
people that do yeah steak tartare is
amazing never happened
yeah i always just assumed you had to
cook it who knows as long as it's good
quality and parasite free
right well don't do chicken yeah i went
to i went to a burger place once
and i got a grilled chicken sandwich and
i was like seen at the bar and the lady
was like what can i get you
and i was like i'll get the chicken
sandwich i'll have that one medium
medium rare
as a joke it was like so the guy next to
me said he wanted his well done
and i said i'll get the chicken sandwich
but i'll have mine medium rare and she
goes okay
and i was like wait i was kidding
[Laughter]
and she went oh yeah then i was like
okay i would have left i would have fled
yeah well i imagine she would have gone
back and the guy would have been like i
can't make a chicken sandwich medium
rare okay good point because of
salmonella
and you can't do it because of
trichonosis but for some reason beef is
okay and fish is okay
yeah yeah well sushi grade sushi grape
fish
yeah otherwise you can get certain fish
let's see coldy locks productions says
we can push russia around because we
broke their backs financially in the
cold war with the star wars project
making them think we were developing
extremely advanced tech
and they tried to match us spending all
their money oh wow crazy
yeah they also just kind of ran out like
central planning doesn't work too well
unfortunately for the soviets right so
they they they learn the hard way that
uh like
freedom and free enterprise do tend to
work pretty effectively sami joel says
tim will you please get flecca's talks
on the show
also i think that biden indiana jones
meme was made by his producer
richard ratboy uh flekas is always
welcome
he has a standing invite and he knows
this we've never had him on have we we
haven't no oh well flecco's come on
you should be on the show ultimate
bow ner it's french i'm imagining it
says so i don't think that oregon would
ever allow those counties to merge into
idaho because then they'd lose all the
money from those counties
it's kind of the same up in washington
with seattle everyone in the state hates
them
that's the problem yeah you know look
you've got to have a strong petition
like you can't
look the left knows how to protest they
know how to occupy an office
or or sit in a street and it works they
put pressure on they get it done
and to be honest they have the advantage
of being able to be violent because you
know
republicans or people on the right are
second class citizens in that regard
if you do anything in any capacity
that's violent they will it'll be every
headline news outlet but antivir can you
know burn down entire cities and
yeah you know it's a peaceful protest
what i'm saying
get organized you know uh you can't just
be like we voted you've got to be like
we are going to boycott we are going to
general strike
imagine if they're like we want these
counties because they make us money and
everyone said
well we're going to go on a general
strike then yep then what are they going
to say
now you're just being hampered by this i
mean wasn't there some big thing like a
bunch of tractors came out and like
blocked roads or something yeah where
was that in finland it was in finland
yeah that's crazy stuff yeah yeah
quint du frey says princess cruise lines
had 45 original cases
yeah i remember that was the first that
was the first one right that's exciting
yeah
good times michael revell says this team
luke tim ian and lydia is great mr
holden is cool too i look forward to
this every night keep up the hard work
well so long as y'all subscribe and go
to the website become members smash the
like button in super chat we'll just
keep doing it because
but the ultimate goals with all of this
is to grow the company and hire more
people and do more awesome work
i love having you on drew it's really
fun thank you as soon as i heard all you
guys names and then mr hold and i was
like oh god i'm gonna get roasted
i was like someone's absolutely gonna
take a shot at me right now and like
i'm sitting here the whole time i was
like oh no no quick quick quick we got
some interesting super chats
kevin bergman says as a fifth generation
oregonian
from the state of jefferson i would
support greater idaho
california has invaded portland pacific
northwest and taken over our politics
mr beard says wyoming here i work in i.t
at a high school we had a delegation
from weld county come through and check
out how our school is like
wyoming already has voiced support i
want to see that happen yeah
that would be easy too it would it would
it would like a pressure release valve
yeah for a lot of the hot politics in
this country
yeah yeah and that's the other thing too
is like there are an enormous number of
benefits but also
talk about an excellent way to decrease
political strife between the parties yes
i i actually lived in weld county for
about a year uh it's a wonderful county
it's very rural
super super like low-key farmers
everything's cool and chill
far cry from like denver and what's the
situation with weld uh what's happening
in the world county they're thinking
about colorado wyoming
they're they're on the board with
wyoming and they want to be a part of
wyoming
yeah who wouldn't right k perdue says
i am canadian our isolation camps are
horrifying
please check out chris skye he sends
ubers to the hotels to help us escape
really i've never in my life what is
going on this is i've never
ever considered any ill will towards
canada or concern or i thought it was
the most free awesome country
like this is terrifying it's always been
pretty bad yeah
yeah all right what do we got toby
walker says curious what ian or any of
you think about cardano over ethereum
solves gas fee and governance issues of
ethereum yeah i don't know anything
about it
i hear it's like the next generation
ethereum really yeah
maybe i will look into it maybe i will
look into it
jonathan wescott says instead of greater
idaho they need new states so they have
less concentrated power
more electoral seats can flip and aren't
held hostage by large states
well look if you make a bun if you break
up a bunch of rural count like counties
into their own states then the
republicans just win
right and and the blue cities are like
yeah it's not fair yeah and no and they
no one will agree with it right even
even writ large and i think that the the
beauty of being able to get into other
states is that you get around
that sort of concern all right the civic
nationalist says the american revolution
was started by smugglers
the t tax was paid in britain and was
propaganda by smugglers because they
didn't want to lose on the monopoly
come back home you can give up this
thing called presidency
sing god save the queen i wonder if
there could ever be any circumstance in
which the u.s decides to be a part of
the the commonwealth again no
as an irish american i i will say i am
strongly against this very idea but
did you guys see that video that went
viral of the irish guy at the checkpoint
oh
my goodness i love that man i'm
channeling him it's just
audio but apparently it's an irish guy
and he pulls up to a checkpoint in
ireland
and then he just starts they're like
how's it going sir where are you going
he's like
none of your goddamn business he
starts yelling at him and then he starts
screaming like
it was really amazing he's like we
fought for 800 years
and now you treat us worse than the
british army did it's just a really
amazing okay i gotta listen to that yeah
this this sounds
incredibly up my alley so it's it's just
audio
but someone shows this like super ripped
farmer guy waving the irish flag and
then it shows like
a cop like a cop like the dog's meme
yeah
amazing it's just it's just crazy audio
where like it's
it's really interesting to hear someone
say like we fought for 800 years and now
you would treat us worse than a british
army and i'm like
that is bold and then the best part oh
man
i don't know a whole lot about politics
and not between ireland and uk just a
little bit on the surface
i know about like the ira i went to
northern ireland i went to uh um
belfast we went there we saw the burning
of the effigies that they have but uh
once a really interesting thing happens
is he's like you believe
the guy the irish guy says you believe
all this stuff you believe all this
stuff
and then he's like do you watch the news
sir and he's like oh the news and he's
like
do you watch rte he's like rte is shite
and then he's like well what about the
bbc
he goes oh the crown news service
found news and i'm like this irish guy
is laying into these people amazing
no but it's really interesting for them
to recommend the bbc to an irish guy i
was like i'd imagine that would piss off
a lot of them
yeah you think that's what i'm going to
be listening to for my news yeah but
then again
look you know we went to belfast i don't
know a whole lot about the internal
politics there's a lot
of history and i i think a lot of it
probably comes down to there's a certain
uh provisional sensibility that some
irish i think have probably in dublin
and the surrounding areas where like
well why wouldn't you like like england
and the rest of the europeans and i
would imagine some of the folks in the
rural areas have a
little bit of a yeah a little bit more
sensitivity about these sorts of things
same as america
all right toby walker says please look
into having a blockchain expert like
charles hoskinson
i also uh on the show i also hope uh
hope you all enjoyed the bushtail coffee
brushtail coffee oh yeah
did we have that no i haven't had it yet
i've been drinking
coffee these days oh yeah i highly
recommend it
it's delicious but uh i'll take the
brushtale politically defiant says tim
idaho already has a seaport it's
lewiston idaho
as the snake river connects to the
columbia river which connects the
pacific ocean via portland
oregon hope everyone has a most
wonderful weekend stay
epically awesome we will have a very
wonderful weekend it will be fun the
weather is getting really nice
good point about the snake river too
i've forgotten that yeah
michael whitten campbell says eastern
washington washington
of washington state talked about this
two years ago or three years ago they
wanted to go to idaho
which would split the state in half
could you imagine if
eastern washington and oregon joined
mega idaho
ultra idaho or just became north idaho
greater idaho and you had north and
south idaho i love it
hey i hope they just called idaho not
greater idaho
i like greater we got a very serious
correction on our on our uh
oh no on our uh thank you chat story
about that
um what what kind of vegetable eggplant
no no no is it the potato see i was
avoiding saying it because he says
excuse me i think you mean mean potatix
we can't say potato anymore because the
o is you know we gotta get rid of this
right
it's gendered or something all right
shoddy viceroy says quick psa completely
off topic
make sure to drink water i had my first
kidney stone and oh boy getting a
catheter hurts a ton
a crap ton worse amen taking another
step great
always a great reminder i was told by
the doctor to put a little bit of lemon
juice in your water but drink it with a
straw
because the acid can be bad for your
teeth and your lips probably
cassius cam says i'm from the state of
jefferson we already call it that up
here
we produce nearly all the beef and water
for california we just want to be left
alone
interesting well then just start acting
like you're the state of jefferson
it sounds like you are they fly the
flags up there the agricultural
differences are curious too right
because i mean i think that that's one
of the other reasons why these places
have so much value why california would
be so unwilling to lose them but why
they'd be so attractive to other places
yeah yeah
hellbound wolf says you talk about fifth
generational warfare
and how our colleges have been
infiltrated by the chinese trans
ideology started in colleges it was our
youth
uh willingly well look i for the sake of
youtube this is too spicy and they're
gonna get me banned if i read the super
chat
so i know they're watching yeah but i'll
just say he's talking about a lot of
leftist politics and and how it's you
know
coming from college higher education
yeah we're all on campus now
in the words of andrew sullivan
everything about american public life
starts on college campuses these days
and transmutes a way off really quickly
that's true
jacob m clutter says tim article 5
doesn't apply to new states or land
transfers that falls under article 4
which requires approval of both states
in question and congressional approval
article 4 convention of states there you
go yeah
good fact trick though casey schultz
says mr potato's head well i'm sorry
potato no it's potato's head
character in tour story oh yes mix
so if mr potato head is bad now then how
long until they try to cancel and erase
that seriously oh boy
i'm surprised they haven't already oh
sparkly story sad
sparky the byros has just had a thought
if mr and mrs potato's head
are are now socially illegal are they
going to digitally remove them from all
this toy story
oh my god amazing know what they're
going to do is they're going to
digitally alter them to be identical
and then and then just have them call
both will be called they'll be referred
to as mix
yeah mixed potato said and mixed potato
said yeah and then they'll have to go in
and they'll have to
change the subtitles so that both of
them are mx
potato heads i'm surprised they're not z
and y i know right
six semper tyrannus says tim in the gang
y'all gotta get a 12.7 millimeter by 99
50 bmg anti-material rifle long live the
republic
god bless y'all and stay safe we will
with that hmm
what an excellent excellent signal
suggestion sounds like that could do
some damage
anti-material meant for destroying
material is that what it is it's for
blowing up helicopters
yeah they're saying it's like yeah
somebody somebody commented in the chat
before and they were like 50 bmg for
when you need to remove
when you need to kill a building yes
please jk says in newfoundland
they put the province under the province
under house arrest
and called an election the size of japan
and six hundred thousand residents
four deaths and months between cases
what did you at
by our provincial greeting what did you
buy i don't think well it's beyond me i
don't live there
but that's insane like that's and again
an empowered government why wouldn't
they
yeah tim says if greater idaho idea
occur
then precedent set counties can vote do
the same dangerous and stupid idea split
divide the u.s like israel palestine it
already is
it's too late look at the look at the
past several elections it's been like 50
50 and struggling you know what i mean
there's no there's no unified
culture anymore it wouldn't be split
like israel and palestine though those
are two different languages and
religions like
that's what it would just be that's
what's happening but i also think that
if you had different states it would be
like as you mentioned earlier a really
good release valve where you wouldn't
have you wouldn't have people who were
resentful and frustrated by the pac the
fact that they had been politically
disenfranchised
you'd just be mad about normal things
but i think that would just redraw lines
and
get us ready for it it would do that a
lot of people would have their hand in
the honey pot trying to
get get a bonus with this what would
happen the red states would become ten
times red or the blue states would
become ten times bluer it would solidify
all the political divide
and that's a really dangerous precedent
but it's it's i don't see
i don't see a way around what's
happening the the the divide in this
country is so insane
that you like i literally tweeted so
there was a there was an image of those
people in those pods
and you know the kids in this year yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i said if you're if
you're crazy enough to do this then you
deserve what you get go vote for
whatever you want
and i got a response from a tribal
leftist i know who says you're so
dumb why would these kids want to spit
on each other and i'm like
slow down there buddy i didn't say the
pods
i didn't say anything it was a picture
of kids in school
for all he knew i could have been saying
if you're stupid enough to go to these
schools in the first place when you are
advocating for them to be closed
the point is how is it that when i say
an image of these kids in these pods
is insane a guy who advocates for
schools to remain closed
is now saying well they should be in the
pods they don't spit on each other no
they shouldn't be in the school
according to you but these people have
no principles
the tribalism is everything i just hate
you
because you're in the wrong tribe and
this is going to lead to people
fighting each other worse than we've
seen in a long time yeah and nothing's
stopping it no the democrats are making
it worse
we went over this the other night with
the echelon insights polls you see this
where republicans were asked to write
their highest their their strongest
concerns oh i did see this
illegal immigration taxation trump
voters were the number one
then white nationalists and then white
supremacy because the democrats
are screaming in the face that
republicans are evil and republicans are
sitting there going
i think illegal immigration is bad for
our economy you know what someone i
think was jessie kelly
said conservatives lost the culture war
because they weren't fighting it yeah
or i'm sorry he said the democrats won
the culture because they were the only
ones fighting it yeah
so you've got all of these people who
are asked and they're conservative
they're republican
what do they care about and they give
you a policy issue there's you're
sitting here as the left is screaming
threatening to go after you to to kick
your your
representatives out of congress to send
the feds to go arrest them
to claim that any kind of violence from
these trump supporters is the end of the
world they're calling it one
six it was one six we need a one-sixth
commission that's what they're saying
yeah
meanwhile antifa burned down all of
these cities
two billion dollars in damage and that
was the insurance cap so it's
substantially more than that
nothing there there is a a battle
happening
there is a conflict going on and look
the solution to whatever it is is
out of my reach i can tell you like i
said over and over again
violence isn't going to solve any of
these things because we're in fifth
generational warfare
so maybe people need to assert their
rights and say
we want an article for convention
to redraw these lines because the very
least then we will have a pressure
release valve
from the people who are the people right
now trapped in these places like in
jefferson
are probably boiling over exactly
exactly give them that release it may be
bad in the long run because it just
hyperpolarizes states
but it's better to alleviate the tension
then let it explode when
what what happens when they say no we
won't give you this reprieve and then
people of jefferson say then we're going
to call our buddies and we're going to
set up a barricade set up our own police
force
exactly and then chaos yeah
yeah i don't know man allison c says
everyone's all worked up about lady
mockingjay's dogs no one gives a damn
about the dog walker who was shot four
times in the chest
elites yeah yeah yeah
he's doing well i guess really he taps
on him yeah he's coming back
it's good poor guy yeah thomas david
says you also get charged 2 thousand
dollars to stay in on those lockdown
hotels in canada
wow pay for that we were talking about
that on the show and it's even steeper
in the united kingdom
that's bad omg puppy says fbi
investigates lady gaga's stolen dogs
in seattle the john brown gun club shot
two black teenagers joyriding through
chas the city doesn't care
welcome to america in 2022 2021
why did i say that because you're a
prophet that's right julius camino says
pretty sure norm mcdonald dave chappelle
and danny devito took the dog
man are they screwed when they get
caught those guys specifically huh
captain spanky says tim i'm in
harney county oregon today was the first
i've heard of greater idaho
our county voted around 75 to 80 trump
hopefully it comes to fruition
yeah well hopefully yeah all right let's
see
dj madero says the state of jefferson
was going to be announced on monday
december 8
1941. just think if they had done it on
friday december 5th 1941
that what would the west coast of the
united states look like today
i mean look california's too big i think
california jefferson
should exist it makes a lot of sense but
you know
then people will you know actually i'm
curious as to what made like
these cities in oregon and seattle and
portland so blue
that turned the whole state under the
control of the democrats you know what i
mean
yeah i think it's just a size thing
right like so many of these these
counties are so sparsely populated that
all it takes is a big city or two that's
overwhelmingly left-leaning and
it's enough to skew it pretty
meaningfully yeah that's why
and and like even washington stated in
oregon even 10 years ago there were at
least a number of republicans right and
like dave they've all
all in one case and most in the other
have been wiped out
all right let's see jonathan mclee says
charlie laduff is now suing governor
whitmer for covering up the coveted
numbers in michigan
accusing her of all the things cuomo has
done ooh interesting we should reach out
to charlie
yeah there's and it seems like there's
pretty good evidence that they they made
a lot of the same decisions that cuomo
did yeah oh yeah they did tons
are covering up all the numbers all
right let's just grab we'll grab one
more super chat eric rivera 219 says
this 20
is for ian tim we tune in for the whole
team you preach freedom of speech but
are always condescending or cutting ian
off
a lot of people think like him well then
i will say he's not always
very rarely but in those heated moments
where we
maybe condescend each other it is not
intentional that is not the goal
tim and i like to go at each other we
don't i mean i don't know i can't speak
for you
i just let myself get heated when i'm
talking to you i find it entertaining
engaging and i'm a better and more
vibrant person afterwards
ladies and gentlemen if you have not
already smash that like button
because it really really does help the
engagement is good for these channels
and subscribe
we are very very close to one million
subscribers please
and uh i think it'll be another month
and a half or so but uh
it might it might pick up you know the
beginning of the year is always kind of
crummy in terms of just like engagement
everyone's kind of worn out especially
after an election
everybody who works the political and
newsbeat knows that like the few months
after any election everyone's like stop
enough i don't want to think about this
anymore and then
you know it just goes down so uh show
your support subscribe like button go to
timcast.com
and we're going to have some uh
exclusive bonus material probably just a
short extra bonus segment today where we
talk about
uh what we're gonna talk about the
golden trump golden truck
and you're gonna want to hear this one
yeah yeah yeah we got some opinions
so uh follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast you can check out
my other youtube channels
youtube.comcast and youtube.comcastnews
check out this podcast every monday
through friday live at 8 pm
and if you're listening on itunes
spotify or any other platform leave us a
good review and give us all those stars
because that also helps us very much
and uh you want to shout anything out
drew no i i don't really have anything
to shout out
go follow the temcast i mean that's what
you should be doing follow us
throw me a follow on twitter too it's
drewholden360 but yeah that's that's all
i got yeah
well on twitter instagram and even
youtube i am
luke we are change my main channel is we
are change and
i forgot to say this i also have like my
own members area that i've been doing it
sporadically for like seven years
on some tips and tricks you can check
that out on we are change.org forward
slash donate and because you do i'm here
so thanks so much for having me guys
you guys can also follow me ian
crossland.net where i sell merchandise
like this
delicious free the code i was drinking
coffee out of earlier it's magnificent
uh drew
coffee always awesome to have yeah adam
kriegler has his own coffee brand called
regular coffee
always awesome having you here man time
flies when you're here i love it i hope
you come back soon
hey pleasure's mine i i thank you guys
for having me seriously it's
it's it's fascinating every time i'm on
here i love the conversation and it does
i mean i
i've never had a moment on here and i'll
be honest i can't always say this about
everywhere i've been but i've never had
a moment here where i'm like what are we
going to talk about next
we've always got something to talk about
five people you know what i mean yeah
different world views and opinions if
you if there's ever like a lull in the
show i'll be like
luke the government
[Music]
ian free the code let's go the federal
reserve oh yeah dmt
yeah okay all the above
i guess that's monday's show no but i'll
it'll be like you'll sense that lull
coming in
and someone will be like i just don't
agree that pac-man was the greatest
character and then as everyone starts to
like slow down i'll go
it's interesting too but i wonder what
the government has to say
what do you think luke yeah well the
government i don't know ron swanson is
my spirit now
right that's great i love him too hey oh
yeah
also i forgot lydia i didn't forget i
was just waiting to uh
yeah i'm here in the corner i pushed the
buttons um i like to talk about the
science
i love the science i really like talking
about it because i worked in the
hospital so anytime we have content
about
covet and stuff i'm always interested in
that but you can follow me on twitter
and mines i'm real
i'm sour patch lids on those platforms
and then i'm real sour patch lids on
instagram and
gab we will see you all over at
timcast.com as we talk about the large
golden trump thanks for hanging out
we'll see you there bye guys
you